I had desired to visit the Hebrides or Western Islands of Scotland so long that I scarcely remember how the wish was originally excited and was, in the autumn of the year 1773, induced to undertake the journey by finding in Mr Boswell a companion whose acuteness would help my inquiry and whose gaiety of conversation and civility of manners are sufficient to counteract the inconveniences of travel in countries less hospitable than we have passed.
我渴望造访苏格兰的赫布里底群岛或西部群岛已经很久了，久到我几乎记不起最初是如何萌生这个念头的。1773年秋，我终于下定决心踏上旅程，因为我找到了鲍斯威尔先生作为旅伴，他的敏锐将有助于我的考察，而他谈吐的愉悦和举止的文雅，足以抵消在比我们所经之地更为荒凉的国度旅行所带来的不便。
On the 18th of August, we left Edinburgh. So that was the son of Litchfield, Samuel Johnson. And he is describing one of the great journeys in all history, one of certainly the most intrepid journeys in all history. And he's describing it in his book, A Journey to the Western Islands of Scotland, which is actually one of the great classics of travel literature. and Johnson, the ultimate Englishman, is describing how for the first time in his life,
8月18日，我们离开了爱丁堡。刚才那位是利奇菲尔德之子，塞缪尔·约翰逊。他正在描述历史上最伟大的旅程之一，当然也是历史上最无畏的旅程之一。他在自己的著作《苏格兰西部群岛游记》中记录了这段经历，该书实际上是旅行文学中的伟大经典之一。约翰逊，这位极致的英国人，正在描述他一生中第一次，
he ventured beyond England's borders. He goes up to the Hebrides, a journey that in the 18th century would have seemed to the average Englishman, especially a Midlander like Johnson, to be going to the very ends of the earth, into the very heart of darkness and the den of savagery, because, of course, you're going to the most Scottish place imaginable. So, Tom, the Western Islands. Have you been to the Western Islands? I have, yes.
他冒险跨越了英国的边界。他前往赫布里底群岛，在18世纪，对于普通英国人，尤其是像约翰逊这样的中部地区人来说，这趟旅程就像是去往世界的尽头，深入黑暗之心和野蛮的巢穴，因为你当然是去往你能想象到的最苏格兰的地方。那么，汤姆，西部群岛。你去过西部群岛吗？我去过，是的。
Savage? Wet, is my chief memory of them. I won't surprise people to hear, but very interesting for all the reasons that Johnson will be discovering and Boswell will be discovering. That's good. Because you mentioned how, to the average Englishman, the Western Isles, the Hebrides, are incredibly remote,
野蛮？我关于它们的主要记忆是潮湿。听到这个大家可能不会感到惊讶，但出于约翰逊和鲍斯威尔即将发现的所有原因，那里非常有趣。很好。因为你提到了对于普通英国人来说，西部群岛、赫布里底群岛是多么遥远，
to Scots in the Lowlands. And this is something that Johnson points out in his book. He says that to most lowlanders, they are as familiar with the Hebrides as they were with Borneo or Sumatra. And this is certainly true of James Boswell, the man mentioned by Johnson as his companion on this great adventure and whose escapades we were hearing about in our previous episode. And Boswell, too, he's an inveterate journal.
对于低地的苏格兰人来说也是如此。这是约翰逊在书中指出的。他说，大多数低地人对赫布里底群岛的熟悉程度，就像他们对婆罗洲或苏门答腊一样。对于詹姆斯·鲍斯威尔来说肯定也是如此，他被约翰逊提及为这次伟大冒险的同伴，我们在上一集里听过他的那些奇遇。鲍斯威尔也是一位习惯性的日记，
writer and the journal that he writes on this trip provides him with the basis for his book because he also gives an account of this journey, the journal of a tour to the Hebrides. And in his introduction to that book, he will spell out what the two men had been hoping to find in the Hebrides. So you summed it up as savagery. Boswell frames it slightly differently. He says that they're looking for simplicity and wildness and all the circumstances of remote time or place so near to our native Great Island, by which he means Great Britain, of course.
作家，他在这次旅行中写的日记为他的书提供了基础，因为他也对这次旅程进行了记述，即《赫布里底群岛游记》。在那本书的序言中，他阐明了两人希望在赫布里底群岛找到什么。你把它总结为野蛮。鲍斯威尔的表述略有不同。他说他们是在寻找纯朴和荒野，以及所有那些离我们本土大岛——他当然是指大不列颠——如此之近的遥远时代或地方的环境。
So before we set off ourselves to the Hebrides, for this extraordinary journey, a thrilling story, let us kick off in a place very close to your heart, Tom, Edinburgh. So Samuel Johnson has arrived for the first time in the Scottish capital. And remember, England and Scotland have only been united in one country since 1707. So if you're quite old, that's within living memory on the 14th of August 1773, which is where we kick off and we're at Boyd's Inn, which is just off the Royal Mile in the heart of Edinburgh. Yes, and Samuel Johnson's arrival there is a great sensation in Edinburgh among polite circles because he is by now one of the most famous people in the whole of Britain. The great cham, they call him the name given to tartar despot. so he's the kind of the supreme monarch of literary Britain.
所以在我们自己出发前往赫布里底群岛，开启这段非凡旅程和惊心动魄的故事之前，让我们从你心中非常亲近的地方开始吧，汤姆，爱丁堡。塞缪尔·约翰逊第一次抵达了苏格兰首府。记住，英格兰和苏格兰自1707年以来才合并为一个国家。所以如果你年纪够大，那在1773年8月14日还属于有生之年的记忆，我们从这里开始，我们在博伊德旅馆，它就在爱丁堡市中心皇家大道旁边。是的，塞缪尔·约翰逊的到来在爱丁堡的上流社会引起了巨大的轰动，因为他现在已经是全英国最著名的人之一了。伟大的汗，他们称呼他，这个名字源于鞑靼专制君主，所以他是英国文学界的最高君主。
And he is also, he's now 64, one of the most recognisable. And Boswell in his journal of a tour to the Hebrides prefaces it with a description of what Johnson looked like over the course of this trip. So Boswell writes, his person was a large, robust, I may say approaching to the gigantic and grown unwieldy from corpulence.
而且他现在64岁了，也是最容易辨认的人之一。鲍斯威尔在《赫布里底群岛游记》中，以对约翰逊在这次旅行中的外貌描述作为序言。鲍斯威尔写道，他的身材高大、魁梧，我甚至可以说接近巨人，且因肥胖而显得笨重。
he has a convulsive twitch, we've mentioned that, he's constantly muttering to himself. And Boswell writes, in the intervals of articulating, he made various sounds with his mouth, sometimes as if ruminating, or what is called chewing the cud, sometimes giving a half whistle,
他有抽搐的毛病，我们提到过，他总是喃喃自语。鲍斯威尔写道，在说话的间隙，他嘴里会发出各种声音，有时好像在反刍，或者所谓的“倒嚼”，有时发出半声口哨，
sometimes making his tongue play backwards from the roof of his mouth, as if clucking like a hen. So he's unprepossessing company, a first appearance. Yeah, I mean, he's distinctive, I think it would be fair to say. Yeah. And he's arrived in Scotland wearing his habitual brown suit, which he'd been wearing the first time that Boswell met him.
有时让舌头在口腔上颚向后弹动，好像母鸡咯咯叫一样。所以他初次见面时并不是一个讨人喜欢的同伴。是的，我的意思是，我认为公平地说，他很有特色。是的。他抵达苏格兰时穿着他那件习惯性的棕色西装，那是鲍斯威尔第一次见到他时穿的那件。
And this time he has brought boots because he suspects it's going to be muddy. It's not wrong. He's got an enormous brown great coat complete with kind of vast pockets. Boswell says he would have been able to fit his own dictionary in the pockets. And he's carrying a large English oak stick. and he also has a pair of pistols with him and a supply of bullets, and this, as Boswell observed, from an erroneous apprehension of violence. So essentially, Johnson thinks the highlands are going to be crawling with bandits,
这次他带了靴子，因为他怀疑路上会很泥泞。他没猜错。他穿着一件巨大的棕色大衣，上面有各种巨大的口袋。鲍斯威尔说他能把自己的字典塞进口袋里。他带着一根巨大的英国橡木手杖，还随身带着一对火枪和一袋子弹，正如鲍斯威尔所观察到的，这是出于对暴力的错误担忧。所以本质上，约翰逊认为高地到处都是强盗，
ruffians and ne'er-do-wells. Bandits and ruffians and all kinds of people. Now, I think that Johnson's critics would not have been surprised that he'd kind of basically come outfitted as John Bull. Because his public image is very much that of a little Englander, a man who essentially judges all the world by the standards of London. You know, his famous saying, the man is tired of London is tired of life. But Boswell knows Johnson very well and appreciates that this public image does not correspond to the private reality. Because the reason that Johnson hasn't travelled is that for most of his life he's been incredibly poor.
恶棍和无赖。强盗、恶棍和各种各样的人。现在，我想约翰逊的批评者们不会对他打扮成“约翰牛”的样子感到惊讶。因为他的公众形象非常像一个狭隘的英国人，一个本质上以伦敦标准来评判全世界的人。你知道，他那句名言，“厌倦了伦敦的人就厌倦了生活”。但鲍斯威尔非常了解约翰逊，并意识到这种公众形象并不符合私下的现实。因为约翰逊没有旅行的原因是，他一生中大部分时间都极其贫穷。
And travel is, relatively speaking, much more expensive in the 80th century. than it is today. And Johnson, all his life, has had an incredibly frustrated yearning to see the world. So he said of Italy, for instance, that, you know, basically a life without seeing Italy isn't a life worth living. He's wanted to go to India. He has a particular thing about the Great Wall of China. Over to Nixon. Well, Nixon gets to see it.
而且相对而言，18世纪的旅行比今天昂贵得多。约翰逊一生中都有着极其强烈的渴望去看看世界。例如，他说过，不看意大利的生活是不值得过的生活。他想去印度。他对中国长城有一种特殊的情结。说到尼克松。好吧，尼克松看到了。
Johnson never did. And so it's rather touching, actually, that in 1922, the first Viscount Rothermear, Dominic. So, the ancestor of your erstwhile employers at the Daily Mail. You're thinking about what to say that. I can see the cogs turning and you're thinking like you don't want to completely put yourself on the wrong side of the Rothermia organization. But equally, you don't want to put yourself on the wrong side of the listeners. What I will say in favour of the first Viscat Rothermia is that knowing of Johnson's yearning to see the Great Wall of China and knowing he's being frustrated, he presented a stone from the Great Wall to Goff House, which was the house in which Johnson had written the diction, which you can still visit to this day. a tremendous place. Oh, that's a lovely thing to have done. So it has this stone from the
约翰逊从未见过。所以，1922年，第一代罗瑟米尔子爵多米尼克做出的举动其实相当感人。那是你以前在《每日邮报》雇主的祖先。你在想该说什么。我能看到你的大脑在转动，你不想完全站在罗瑟米尔组织的对立面。但同样，你也不想站在听众的对立面。关于第一代罗瑟米尔子爵，我想说的是，他知道约翰逊渴望看到中国长城却未能如愿，于是他向高夫故居赠送了一块长城的石头，那是约翰逊编写字典的地方，至今仍可参观，一个了不起的地方。哦，那真是件美妙的事情。所以它有这块来自
Great Wall there. Yeah, great credit to Viscount Rotherma for that. I think it's the only stone from the Great Wall in the whole of London. So, brilliant. That's an interesting fact. And so Boswell knows this. And so this is why essentially he had been confident in urging Boswell to come to Scotland, because he knows that Johnson specifically had wanted to see the Hebrides, because Johnson had read about the Hebrides when he was a child. And so it's a kind of childhood fantasy to go there. So, Boswell comes scurring along to this inn off the,
长城的石头在那里。是的，罗瑟米尔子爵为此功不可没。我想这是整个伦敦唯一一块来自长城的石头。太棒了。这是一个有趣的事实。鲍斯威尔知道这一点。这就是为什么他一直有信心敦促鲍斯威尔来苏格兰，因为他知道约翰逊特别想看赫布里底群岛，因为约翰逊小时候读过关于赫布里底群岛的书。所以去那里是一种童年的幻想。于是，鲍斯威尔匆匆赶到皇家大道旁的这家旅馆，
of the Royal Mile, and he's delighted to see Johnson, isn't he? Yeah. He's very excited. But he's a little bit nervous because he's worried that Johnson will embarrass him by bursting out, twitching and shouting his anti-Skottish prejudices,
他见到约翰逊很高兴，不是吗？是的。他非常兴奋。但他有点紧张，因为他担心约翰逊会因为突然抽搐和高喊反苏格兰偏见而让他难堪，
which would be very bad. Because Johnson is notorious for anti-Scottish prejudice. You know, he's always following. dominating that Scotland's very poor, everyone eats out, and that the Scots are forever fleeing Scotland for England. And Boswell, of course, is an example of that. So, as you say, Boswell is nervous. He takes Johnson by the arm, and so arm in arm, they walk up the Royal Mile towards his house, which is just off it. And as they go, Boswell finds himself mortified by what he describes as the evening effluvia. So essentially, the stench of drains. A zealous Scotsman would have wished Mr. Johnson to be without one of his five senses
那会非常糟糕。因为约翰逊以反苏格兰偏见而闻名。你知道，他总是说苏格兰很穷，每个人都吃不饱，苏格兰人总是逃离苏格兰去英格兰。鲍斯威尔当然就是个例子。所以，正如你所说，鲍斯威尔很紧张。他挽着约翰逊的手臂，两人挽着手沿着皇家大道走向他家，他家就在旁边。走着走着，鲍斯威尔发现自己被他所描述的“晚间秽气”弄得尴尬不已。本质上，就是下水道的恶臭。一位热心的苏格兰人会希望约翰逊先生在此时此刻失去五感中的一种。
upon this occasion. As we marched slowly along, he grumbled in my ear, I smell you in the dark. So that's not a good start. And then two days later, there is going to be more harrumphing, because it's provoked by what remains 60 foot four years on. Yeah. The single most controversial issue in Anglo-Scottish relations, and you just mentioned it, it's the Act of Union, which had dissolved the Parliaments of England and Scotland, and created a united kingdom of Great Britain. And as you said, this act had been passed in 1707, and the Scottish Act of Union is kept in the Parliament House, which stands just off the Royal Mile by St. Giles Cathedral. And Boswell takes Johnson there, and Johnson is shown the document.
当我们缓慢前行时，他在我耳边嘟囔道：“我在黑暗中闻到了你的味道。”所以这可不是个好的开始。两天后，会有更多的抱怨，因为这是由44年后依然存在的问题引发的。是的。英苏关系中最具争议的问题，你刚才提到了，就是《联合法案》，它解散了英格兰和苏格兰的议会，建立了大不列颠联合王国。正如你所说，该法案于1707年通过，苏格兰的《联合法案》保存在圣吉尔斯大教堂旁边的议会大厦里。鲍斯威尔带约翰逊去了那里，约翰逊看到了这份文件。
And as Johnson is inspecting it, Boswell began, in his own words, to indulge old Scottish sentiments and to express a warm regret that by our union with England, we were no more. Ooh. The SMP enter the chat. Boswell knows what he's doing. He's winding Johnson up. He knows that Johnson is going to explode.
当约翰逊检查它时，鲍斯威尔用他自己的话说，开始“沉溺于古老的苏格兰情怀，并表达了一种热切的遗憾，即由于我们与英格兰的联合，我们不复存在了。”哦。苏格兰民族党加入聊天了。鲍斯威尔知道自己在做什么。他在激怒约翰逊。他知道约翰逊会爆发。
But Johnson responds in a perhaps unexpected way. Sir, never talk of your independency. Who could let your queen remain 20 years in captivity and then be put to death without even a pretence of justice without your ever attempting to rescue her? and such a queen too. So he's talking about Mary Queen of Scots and saying that because the Scots hadn't tried to rescue her from captivity in England,
但约翰逊以一种或许出乎意料的方式回应了。先生，永远不要谈论你们的独立。是谁让你们的女王在囚禁中度过20年，然后被处死，甚至没有假装公正，而你们却从未试图营救她？而且还是那样一位女王。所以他谈论的是苏格兰玛丽女王，并说因为苏格兰人没有试图将她从英格兰的囚禁中救出来，
therefore they don't deserve to be independent. Yeah. Which is perhaps an argument that might defeat the SMP if it gets unleashed now. I mean, who knows. And they're overheard, aren't they, by the keep of the records, or who's standing at their elbow?
所以他们不配独立。是的。这或许是一个如果现在拿出来用，可能会击败苏格兰民族党的论点。我的意思是，谁知道呢。他们被偷听了，不是吗？被站在他们手肘边的记录保管员。
Yes. And he says a thing that you actually often hear, you often see online to this day, half our nation was braibed by English money. This is basically the sort of ultra-Scottish nationalist take on Scottish history and on the Act of Union, saying that basically our elite were bribed by the English to sell our independence. And John's brilliant answer. Sir, that's no defence. That makes you worse.
是的。他说了一句你今天在网上经常听到、经常看到的话：“我们国家的一半是被英国人的钱收买的。”这基本上是苏格兰极端民族主义者对苏格兰历史和《联合法案》的看法，认为我们的精英被英国人收买以出卖我们的独立。约翰逊的精彩回答是：先生，那不是辩护。那让你们更糟糕。
I mean, it's not wrong. Yeah. Yeah. To use the word we used in the very first episode, this is all very performative, isn't it? They're basically going through the motions, having a bit of fun, playing their parts. Yeah, I think so. I mean, it's self-consciously banter, I think. Right.
我的意思是，他没说错。是的。是的。用我们在第一集里用过的词，这一切都非常具有表演性，不是吗？他们基本上是在走过场，找点乐子，扮演各自的角色。是的，我想是这样。我的意思是，我认为这是自觉的玩笑。没错。
And it's exactly what Boswell wanted, because then you can go back and write it up, and here we are talking about it all these years on. But I think that Johnson's devotion to Mary Queen of Scots, I mean, on one level it seems completely unexpected kind of tangent. But on the other, it's a reminder that there are actually much rorer and fresher political emotions kind of edding around in Scotland than those generated by the Act of Union. Three decades previously, so this is in 1744,
这正是鲍斯威尔想要的，因为这样他就可以回去把它写下来，而我们多年后还在谈论它。但我认为约翰逊对苏格兰玛丽女王的忠诚，在某种程度上似乎是一个完全出乎意料的偏题。但另一方面，这提醒人们，苏格兰实际上存在着比《联合法案》所产生的更原始、更鲜活的政治情绪。三十年前，也就是1744年，
the great, great, great grandson of Mary Queen of Scots, Charles Stewart, who is better known as Bonnie Prince Charlie, he'd landed from France in Scotland. And he had raised an army in the Highlands and led them southwards as far as Derby in the Midlands. They're actually not far from Litchfield. And Bonnie Prince Charlie's aim was to overthrow the ruling British dynasty, the House of Hanover. and they were Protestants, the Stuets are Catholic, and so the Protestant establishment had essentially brought in the House of Hanover to replace the Catholic House of Stuart.
苏格兰玛丽女王的玄孙，查尔斯·斯图亚特，也就是更广为人知的“英俊王子查理”，他从法国登陆苏格兰。他在高地组建了一支军队，并带领他们向南一直打到中部地区的德比。他们离利奇菲尔德其实不远。英俊王子查理的目标是推翻统治英国的王朝——汉诺威王朝。他们是新教徒，斯图亚特家族是天主教徒，所以新教建制派本质上引进了汉诺威王朝来取代天主教的斯图亚特王朝。
And this is why in the 18th century you have kind of waves of King George's ruling all the time. And Bonnie Prince Charlie wants to overthrow this and claim the throne for his father, King James III, as loyalists to Jacobus, as he's called in Latin. So Jacobites, think of him. Unfortunately, he can't reach London.
这就是为什么在18世纪你总是看到一波又一波的乔治国王统治。英俊王子查理想要推翻这一点，并为他的父亲詹姆斯三世国王夺回王位，正如拉丁语中称呼的那样，他是雅各布派的忠诚者。所以雅各布派，想到他。不幸的是，他没能到达伦敦。
He retreats, he withdraws to the Highlands, and there he is cornered at Caluddin, a village by Inverness in the northeast corner of Scotland, and his army had been annihilated. Bonnie Prince Charlie had managed to escape the battlefield, but he has this completely hair-raising kind of flight across the Highlands. He gets to the Hebrides, and he only manages to get on board a ship and sail back to France by the absolute skin of his teeth. Now, three decades on, from that great adventure, the prospects of the Stuarts returning to the British throne and replacing the Hanoverians are obviously, I mean, effectively zero. But there are still those who preserve a wistful loyalty to them. And we mentioned in our very first episode how one of those
他撤退了，他撤退到高地，在那里他在苏格兰东北角的因弗内斯附近的卡洛登村被围困，他的军队被歼灭了。英俊王子查理设法逃离了战场，但他经历了极其惊险的穿越高地的逃亡。他到达了赫布里底群岛，并且仅仅是侥幸登上一艘船逃回了法国。现在，距离那次伟大的冒险已经过去三十年了，斯图亚特家族重返英国王位并取代汉诺威王朝的前景显然，我的意思是，实际上为零。但仍有人对他们保持着一种忧郁的忠诚。我们在第一集里提到过，其中之一
is Samuel Johnson. Boswell says all his youth, he had felt a tenderness for that unfortunate house. So the Stuarts. That's a common thing among Tories. So Tories had this kind of this sort of nostalgic loyalty to the House of Stuart, didn't they? Yeah. And Johnson, even as a young man,
就是塞缪尔·约翰逊。鲍斯威尔说，他年轻时对那个不幸的家族怀有一种柔情。也就是斯图亚特家族。这在托利党人中很常见。所以托利党人对斯图亚特家族有一种怀旧的忠诚，不是吗？是的。约翰逊，即使在年轻时，
would have perhaps, maybe there's a slight element of affectation about it, but this so often is with political positions. I mean, it doesn't undermine them. I mean, it's interesting you say that. I mean, I think that's true to a degree. But in his life of Johnson,
可能也会有轻微的矫揉造作的成分，但这在政治立场上经常发生。我的意思是，这并没有削弱它们。我的意思是，你这么说很有趣。但我认为在某种程度上是事实。但在他的《约翰逊传》中，
Boswell will point out that perhaps his affections might have gone beyond mere tenderness, because he writes it is somewhat curious that his literary career appears to have been almost totally suspended in the years 1745 and 1746. So those are the years that Bonnie Prince Charlie
鲍斯威尔会指出，也许他的感情可能不仅仅是柔情，因为他写道：“有些奇怪的是，他的文学事业在1745年和1746年似乎完全停滞了。”所以那些年正是英俊王子查理
is in Britain trying to seize the throne. But wasn't he developing the idea of the dictionary at that point? So that's why he's so quiet. He definitely was by the time Clutton comes. Earlier, yeah, it's unclear. And there are a few scholars who suggest that perhaps he was actually embroiled in the campaign. I mean, I think he's
在英国试图夺取王位的时候。但那时他不是在构思字典吗？所以他才那么安静。到卡洛登战役时他肯定在构思。更早的时候，是的，不清楚。有一些学者认为，也许他实际上卷入了这场运动。我的意思是，我认为他
unlikely. I mean, he's the last person you'd want on your side, shambling with his massive pockets. Yes, I think it's unlikely. But it's probable that he was lying low. Okay. He probably was known as a Jacobite and so probably thought that, you know, it was sensible not to draw attention to it. Not anymore though, right?
不太可能。我的意思是，他是你最不想拉拢的人，拖着巨大的口袋蹒跚而行。是的，我认为不太可能。但很可能他当时在躲避风头。好吧。他可能被认为是雅各布派，所以可能认为保持低调是明智的。不过现在不是了，对吧？
The King George has given him a pension and didn't he meet the king in 1767, George III, at the library? Yeah, in the Royal Library at Windsor. And so, I mean, Johnson's apologetic about this. Remember, we discussed, he's been told this is a kind of reward for doing the dictionary. You don't have to serve as a kind of propagandist for the Hanoverians. But even so, I mean, Johnson appreciates, you know, as he says to Boswell, I cannot now curse the House of
乔治国王给了他养老金，而且他不是在1767年在图书馆见过国王乔治三世吗？是的，在温莎的皇家图书馆。所以，我的意思是，约翰逊对此表示歉意。记住，我们讨论过，他被告知这是编写字典的奖励。你不必充当汉诺威王朝的宣传员。但即便如此，我的意思是，约翰逊很感激，正如他对鲍斯威尔所说，我不能现在诅咒汉诺威王朝。
Hanover. But he says that with a smile. I think that one of the reasons why Johnson does feel fondly towards Boswell is that he knows that Boswell also shares in these sympathies. So Boswell's father, Lord Affleck, he's a wig and he's a massive supporter of the House of Hanover. All right. So, yeah. But Boswell, right from childhood, seems to have had this kind of romantic affection for Bonnie Prince Charlie. And it may be, you know, so 1745 when Bonnie Prince Charlie lands, Boswell is four years old. And so this may be the first kind of political intervention that he's become aware of. Surely, yeah.
但他微笑着说了那句话。我认为约翰逊对鲍斯威尔感到亲切的原因之一是，他知道鲍斯威尔也分享这些同情。所以鲍斯威尔的父亲，阿夫莱克勋爵，他是辉格党人，是汉诺威王朝的坚定支持者。好吧。所以，是的。但鲍斯威尔，从小似乎就对英俊王子查理有一种浪漫的感情。而且可能是，你知道，1745年英俊王子查理登陆时，鲍斯威尔四岁。所以这可能是他意识到的第一次政治干预。当然，是的。
He clearly sees Bonnie Prince Charlie as a very romantic. character and supports him, even though it has to be said, he's offered a coin by a servant if he will shout God save King George, which he takes, and he does shout it. But having pocketed it, he then goes back to his kind of Jacobite sympathies. He basically stays loyal in a kind of, as you say, slightly performative way for all his life. And actually, when he was in Corsica, he had kind of mad fantasies about maybe seeing that the Stuarts established on the island of Corsica. That completely should have happened. Should that not have happened? the Stuart Kingdom of Gorsica?
他显然把英俊王子查理看作一个非常浪漫的人物并支持他，尽管必须说，如果他高喊“上帝保佑乔治国王”，仆人会给他一枚硬币，他拿了，他也喊了。但把钱装进口袋后，他又回到了那种雅各布派的同情中。他基本上以一种你所说的稍微表演性的方式忠诚了一辈子。实际上，当他在科西嘉岛时，他曾有过疯狂的幻想，也许能看到斯图亚特家族在科西嘉岛建立政权。那完全应该发生。那不应该发生吗？斯图亚特科西嘉王国？
Well, of history's great, great what ifs. It would have stopped Napoleon. Yeah. So I think that obviously Johnson and Boswell do have this fascination. And by this point, it may be nothing more than that with Bonnie Prince Charlie. You know, the whole story, it's very romantic. His defeat at Caleddon, his escape across the highlands, you know, the fact he takes refuge on the Hebrides. And I think it is definitely an important, motivated.
好吧，这是历史上伟大的“如果”之一。那会阻止拿破仑。是的。所以我认为约翰逊和鲍斯威尔显然对英俊王子查理有这种迷恋。到目前为止，这可能仅仅是迷恋而已。你知道，整个故事非常浪漫。他在卡洛登的失败，他穿越高地的逃亡，你知道，他躲在赫布里底群岛的事实。我认为这绝对是一个重要的动机，
for both of them in making this trip. And I think it also helps to explain the route that they end up taking because the obvious route to the Western Isles from Edinburgh is, duh, to go westwards. But Johnson and Boswell opt instead to take a much more roundabout route. They take the eastern road out of Scotland, up the coast, going northwards towards Inverness. and Inverness, of course, is a place that is very close to Kalluddin.
对他们两人来说，进行这次旅行。而且我认为这也解释了他们最终选择的路线，因为从爱丁堡到西部群岛最明显的路线是向西走。但约翰逊和鲍斯威尔选择了绕远路。他们走苏格兰的东路，沿着海岸向北前往因弗内斯。而因弗内斯，当然，是一个离卡洛登非常近的地方。
And to get from Inverness, they'll be going down, Loch Ness, and then across the hills and across the sea to the Western Isles. That is basically the route that Bonnie Prince Charlie had taken. And it's incredibly picturesque. I mean, it's ticking every box that route. Yeah. Do you think it is a sort of a Jacobite tour for them? I mean, genuinely, they've designed it accordingly. I think so, yes.
从因弗内斯出发，他们将沿着尼斯湖，然后穿过山丘，跨过大海到达西部群岛。这基本上就是英俊王子查理走过的路线。而且风景极其优美。我的意思是，那条路线满足了所有条件。是的。你认为这对他们来说是一种“雅各布派之旅”吗？我的意思是，他们确实是相应地设计的。我想是的，是的。
Hmm, nice. It's one of many factors. But I think for both of them, the sense of the romance in Bonnie Prince Charlie's story lends an extra patener of excitement to the scenes that they're going to be seeing in the Highlands, I think, absolutely. Excitingly for them, they will also get to visit one of my alma martyrs, whatever the plural of alma mater is. Oh, yeah, St Andrews.
嗯，不错。这是众多因素之一。但我认为对他们两人来说，英俊王子查理故事中的浪漫感为他们即将在高地看到的场景增添了一层额外的兴奋感，我认为绝对是这样。令他们兴奋的是，他们还将参观我的母校之一，无论母校的复数是什么。哦，是的，圣安德鲁斯。
So, very exciting. So they're about to set off. Johnson has had a tremendous time in Edinburgh, hasn't he? He actually liked it, despite the stench. He does. So he keeps landing what Boswell calls his pleasant hits against Scotland. But actually, he's pretty well behaved. He's genuinely impressed by the beauties of Edinburgh and its architecture.
所以，非常令人兴奋。所以他们即将出发。约翰逊在爱丁堡度过了一段美妙的时光，不是吗？他实际上很喜欢那里，尽管有恶臭。他确实喜欢。所以他不断地对他所谓的“对苏格兰的愉快打击”进行评价。但实际上，他表现得相当好。他确实对爱丁堡的美景及其建筑印象深刻。
And he's very flattered by the kind of the great host of Edinburgh luminaries who come to visit him in Boswell's house. Really enjoys their company. And of course, Edinburgh, I mean, Edinburgh is not an intellectual backwater. This is the great age of the Scottish Enlightenment. And there are lots of people who it's well worth Johnson meeting. So he, I think, really enjoys Edinburgh. They leave Edinburgh on the 18th of August, and they have with them a single servant who is absolutely massive bohemian,
而且他被那些来到鲍斯威尔家中拜访他的爱丁堡名流所奉承。真的很享受他们的陪伴。当然，爱丁堡，我的意思是，爱丁堡不是一个知识荒地。这是苏格兰启蒙运动的伟大时代。有很多人值得约翰逊去见。所以，我想他真的很喜欢爱丁堡。他们于8月18日离开爱丁堡，随行的是一名单一的仆人，他是一个绝对巨大的波希米亚人，
very well-travelled, speaks lots of languages. Frederick the Great would have loved him, would have enrolled him in his army. They obviously want someone who's huge, because Johnson is clearly still a bit nervous about what they're going to be finding in the highlands. So they leave Edinburgh, as I say, they're heading eastwards, and they head for St Andrews, Scotland's oldest university and a city described by Johnson as once arch-episcopal, meaning there had once been an archbishop there, but the Scottish Reformation had then destroyed it. And Johnson does not approve of this at all and thinks that John Knox is an absolutely terrible man and laments it. He's treated very well again by the professors, all of whom are thrilled to meet him. but he does find the city unhappily declined.
非常见多识广，会说多种语言。腓特烈大帝会喜欢他的，会把他招进军队的。他们显然想要一个身材魁梧的人，因为约翰逊显然仍然对他们在高地会发现什么感到有点紧张。所以他们离开爱丁堡，正如我所说，他们向东走，前往圣安德鲁斯，苏格兰最古老的大学，也是约翰逊描述为“曾经的大主教区”的城市，意味着那里曾经有一位大主教，但苏格兰宗教改革摧毁了它。约翰逊对此一点也不赞同，认为约翰·诺克斯是一个绝对可怕的人，并为此感到悲哀。教授们再次对他非常好，他们都为能见到他而感到激动。但他确实发现这座城市“不幸地衰落了”。
So he writes, one of its streets is now lost, and in those that remain, there is the silence and solitude of inactive indigence and gloomy depopulation. There is something quite gloomy about St Andrews. So it's out on the east coast of Scotland, you've got nothing between you
所以他写道：“它的一条街道现在消失了，在剩下的街道里，有一种不活跃的贫困和阴郁的人口减少带来的沉默和孤独。”圣安德鲁斯确实有些阴郁。它位于苏格兰东海岸，你和西伯利亚风之间什么都没有。
and the kind of Siberian winds. It can be very cold. And you're a long way from anywhere. Yeah, I think for Johnson, though, it's not just that, you know, there are the ruins of, you know, bare ruined choirs and all of that. the Marx of the Scottish Reformation.
那里可能非常冷。而且你离任何地方都很远。是的，我想对约翰逊来说，不仅仅是那里有废墟，你知道，那些光秃秃的废墟唱诗班等等。苏格兰宗教改革的痕迹。
It's also that it does seem to be very depopulated. It's clearly not as flourishing as it once was. And this will become one of the great themes of his book on the Highlands, this sense that there are parts of Scotland, the lowlands that are absolutely booming. But there are other parts, and particularly the more northerly reaches that are clearly not. And the whole trip, Johnson is brooding on this. And actually, he has a lot of time to think, because the journey is quite a long one. and going from St Andrews up towards Aberdeen, you know, the coach is kind of bumping around on the roads.
这也是因为它看起来确实人口非常稀少。它显然不像以前那样繁荣了。这将成为他关于高地的书中的伟大主题之一，这种感觉是苏格兰的部分地区，低地，绝对是在蓬勃发展。但还有其他地区，特别是更北部的地区，显然不是。整个旅程，约翰逊都在沉思这个问题。实际上，他有很多时间思考，因为旅程相当漫长。从圣安德鲁斯向阿伯丁走，你知道，马车在路上颠簸。
And Johnson, who isn't usually a man to complain, but he is, I think, slightly feeling his age. And there's one particularly long and dreary stretch of road in the approaches to Aberdeen. He goes so far as to worry about how on earth he is going to cope riding a horse. And he tells Bosn, well, if we must ride much, we shall not go and there's an end on. and I have to say that there's an end on is one of my favourite phrases from Johnson but the next day he's cheered up and Boswell joshes him about the fact that he'd been
约翰逊，他通常不是一个爱抱怨的人，但我认为他稍微感觉到了自己的年龄。在接近阿伯丁的路上有一段特别漫长而沉闷的路。他甚至担心自己该如何骑马。他告诉鲍斯威尔：“如果我们必须骑马，我们就不去了，到此为止。”我必须说，“到此为止”是我最喜欢的约翰逊短语之一。但第二天他振作起来了，鲍斯威尔嘲笑他担心马匹，总是陷入自怜，说：“为什么，先生，你昨天开始灰心丧气了，你是个娇气的伦敦人，你是个花花公子，你不会骑马。”哦，那真是精彩的玩笑。所以约翰逊绝对会，尽管他会，我的意思是，那会强迫他骑马。
worrying about horses and kind of always lapsing into self-pity says, why sir you was beginning to despond yesterday you're a delicate Londoner, you're a macaroni you can't ride oh that's great banter so Johnson would absolutely despite he would I mean that would force him to ride
是的，他不会接受被称为“花花公子”。不，因为花花公子是那些穿着夸张的意大利时装、戴着巨大假发的人。那根本不是约翰逊的风格。约翰逊对此非常愤慨：“先生，我会骑得比你好。我只是担心我找不到一匹能载得动我的马。”必须说，这是一个合理的担忧，因为正如我们所说，他此时已经非常巨大了。是的。那天晚上他们到达了阿伯丁。他们到了旅馆。旅馆满了。鲍斯威尔提到了他的家族姓氏，立刻就为他们找到了房间。所以这是衡量声誉的标准，如果不是鲍斯威尔本人的，也是他父亲阿夫莱克勋爵的。
yes he's not going to take being called a macaroni. No, because macaronies are people who dress in exaggerated Italian fashions with enormous wigs. That's not Johnson's vibe at all. And Johnson is very indignant about it and sir, I shall ride better than you. I was only afraid I should not find a horse able to carry me. Which has to be said, is a reasonable worry because he is, as we say, enormous by this point. Yeah. So that evening they arrive in Aberdeen. They get to the inn. The inn is full. Boswell mentions his family name and immediately a room is found for them. So that's a measure of the reputation, if not of Boswell himself, of his father, Lord
第二天在阿伯丁，约翰逊再次受到追捧，城市长老们对他的到来感到如此兴奋，以至于他们投票授予他城市自由权。所以约翰逊现在心情好多了。而且更重要的是，他们现在开始接近他所希望的那种崇高的景观，因为，引用鲍斯威尔的话，他总是说他来苏格兰不是为了看英格兰已经足够多的优美地方，而是为了看“野性的物体、山脉、瀑布、独特的风俗”。所以再次，有一种浪漫主义的感觉，不是吗？对那种野蛮和荒野的热爱，你知道，抛弃城市的虚饰，进入自然。是的，约翰逊常被认为
Affleck. And the next day in Aberdeen, Johnson gets lionized again, and the city elders are so excited to have him in their presence that they actually vote in the freedom of the city. So Johnson is now in a much better mood. And what is more, they are now starting to approach the sublime kind of landscape that he's been hoping for, because, to quote Boswell, he always said that he was not come to Scotland to see fine places of which there were enough in England, but wild objects, mountains, waterfalls, peculiar manners. So again, there's that sense of romanticism, isn't there, the love of the kind of savage and the wildness and all of that kind of thing, you know, casting off the veneer of the city and getting into nature. Yeah, and Johnson is often thought
是一个古典人物，你知道，他的拉丁语和他对伦敦的热爱等等。但他来苏格兰是为了看荒野，所以他将看到荒野。对于鲍斯威尔来说，这种对野外风景的热情可能有多么令人担忧，这是一个预演，因为他们参观了巴肯的布勒斯，这是一条狂野的海岸步道，环绕着当地称为“壶”的沸腾水域。鲍斯威尔，实际上，我的意思是，他看到身材极其肥胖的约翰逊走在这条岩石架上，下面是冷酷的岩石和沸腾的水，他感到非常害怕。看着约翰逊先生摸索着前行真是令人担忧。我想鲍斯威尔在想，如果英国文学界最伟大的人坠落身亡，那会怎么样？那看起来可一点都不好。无论如何，约翰逊幸存了下来，上了马车，他非常高兴。但鲍斯威尔，反思约翰逊坠落身亡的可能性，他突然成了阴郁幻想的猎物。因弗内斯周围的风景和文学联想加剧了他的恐惧。所以到8月26日下午，他们正开车穿过麦克白在莎士比亚戏剧开头被认为遇见三位女巫的荒原。鲍斯威尔发现自己因恐惧而颤抖。
as a kind of, you know, classical figure, you know, his Latin and his love of London and all of that. But he has come to Scotland to see wilderness, and so wilderness he is going to see. And there's a taster for Boswell of how potentially alarming this enthusiasm for wild scenery might be, because they visit the Bullers of Buckin, which is a wild coastal walk that goes around very boiling waters known locally as the pot. And Boswell, actually, I mean, he's terrified to see the hugely corpulent Johnson kind of striding along this. rocky ledge with grim rocks and boiling waters below him. It was rather alarming to see Mr Johnson poking his way. And I guess Boswell is thinking, well, how's it going to play if, you know, the greatest
他把自己逼入了一种绝对的状态。然后，当他们在荒原上颠簸时，他们看到了。他们看到了一个强盗在绞刑架上腐烂的尸体。那个强盗已经在那里两个月了。鲍斯威尔，他将其描述为“那种我总是对任何阴郁事物都有的好奇心”，爬出马车检查它。必须说，鲍斯威尔对绞刑很有研究。
man of British letters plunges to his death? That's not going to be a good look at all. Anyway, Johnson survives it and gets in the coach and he's very happy. But Boswell, I think, reflecting on the possibility of Johnson falling to his death, he's suddenly become prey to gloomy fancies. and the landscape and the literary associations around Infaness kind of play on his fears. So by the afternoon of the 26th of August, they're driving across the heath where Macbeth was supposed to have met the three witches at the start of Shakespeare's play. Boswell finds himself shivering in terror.
我认为这不是因为他是虐待狂或类似的人。我认为恰恰相反。我认为这是因为他被死亡所压迫，并敢于直面它。他会去和那些即将被绞死的人交谈，然后看着他们被绞死，然后检查他们的尸体。我认为这是一种直面死亡必然性的方式。
And he's working himself up into an absolute state. And then, as they're rattling along across this heath, they see. they see the rotting body of a highwayman in a gibbet. The highwayman has been there for two months. And Boswell, he describes it as that strange curiosity, which I always have about anything dismal, climbs out of the coach and inspects it. And it has to be said that Boswell has quite a thing about hangings.
所以他对这件事的反应，我的意思是，在这里变得更奇怪了。是的。是他会出去和一个妓女发生性关系。我想是为了感觉活着。显然，那里有很深的水。但鲍斯威尔也这样做，我的意思是，他对任何事情的反应。我的意思是，他对母亲去世的反应是去妓院。
It isn't, I think, because he's a sadist or anything like this. I think it's actually the opposite. I think it's because he is oppressed by more. and kind of dares himself to stare it in the face. He would go and talk to people who were about to be hanged and then watch them be hanged and then inspect their bodies afterwards. And it's kind of staring the inevitability of death in the face, I think.
我的意思是，我知道。但我想这正是让他成为一个如此迷人的人的原因，他有所有这些奇怪的生活观，这些奇怪的方法，这些奇怪的情绪，但他只是把它们写了下来。奇怪的方法总是以某种方式回到同一个目的地，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，那是一个目的地，但我们说的另一个目的地是这种几乎是对把自己逼入恐惧和死亡恐惧状态的热情。
And so his response to this often, I mean, here it gets even weirder. Yes. Is that he would go out and have sex with a prostitute. I think to feel alive. Obviously, there's very deep waters there. But also, Boswell does that, I mean, his response to anything. I mean, his response to the death of his mum was to go to a brothel.
那天晚上，他完全是病态的。约翰逊要么没认出来，要么想戏弄鲍斯威尔。所以鲍斯威尔写道，约翰逊先生不知道我的，你知道，基本上是我处于极度恐惧中的事实。或者他事后告诉我，他不会那样说话，因为他以试图吓唬我为乐，好像女巫会来在我的床脚跳舞一样。所以你可以想象，你知道，约翰逊基本上给鲍斯威尔讲了很多鬼故事。是的。鲍斯威尔在床上颤抖。所以如果你对鬼魂和死亡感兴趣，这里有两个非常令人兴奋的地方。
I mean, I know. I mean, but this I think is what makes him such a fascinating man, is that he has all these kind of, these strange takes on life, these strange approaches, these strange emotions, but he just writes them up. Strange approaches that always somehow come back to the same destination, no? Yeah, well, I mean, that is one destination, but another destination we say is this kind of this kind of enthusiasm almost for working himself up into a state. of terror and dread of death.
所以在去因弗内斯的路上，还有两个大景点要看。一个是麦克白的城堡，也就是考多城堡，另一个是卡洛登战场，我们已经听说过了。那么让我们从麦克白的城堡开始。他们确实参观了麦克白的城堡。那是谁的？在那个年代是怎么运作的？一定有人住在那里，还是它是废墟？它是废墟，但有一位当地牧师招待了他们。他们去检查了城堡，鲍斯威尔对此感到高兴，
And that evening he is, you know, completely morbid. And Johnson either doesn't recognize it or wants to tweak Boswell's tale. So Boswell writes that Mr. Johnson did not know of my, you know, basically the fact that I was in a massive funk. Or he told me afterwards he would not have talked as he did, for he diverted himself with trying to frighten me as if the witches would come and dance at the foot of my bed. So you can imagine, you know, Johnson basically telling Boswell lots of ghost stories. Yeah. Boswell kind of gibbering in his bed. So if you're interested ghosts and death, two very exciting places to come.
不是因为城堡本身。而是塞缪尔·约翰逊先生在这个偏远地方及其所有文学联想的奇观。事实上，他那天晚上给伟大的演员大卫·加里克写了一封信。确实，正如我一直习惯于看待他，约翰逊博士，作为一个永久的伦敦对象，看到圣保罗教堂移动到我们现在所在的地方，对我来说不会更奇妙了。我认为在整个旅程中，你有这种感觉，鲍斯威尔就像一个纪录片导演。没错。他把一个人从舒适的环境中移走，放在一个可能发生各种冒险的地方。
So on the road to Inverness, two more big sites to look at. One of them is Macbeth's Castle, so the Castle of Cordo, and the other is the Battlefield of Collodon, which we've already heard about. So let's start with Macbeth's Castle. So they do visit Macbeth's Castle. It's own, how does that work in those days? Somebody must live there or is it ruined? It's ruined, but there's a local minister who entertains them. And they go and inspect the castle and Boswell is delighted by it,
他总是把约翰逊框在他的脑海里。我有一个叫罗里的朋友，曾经带丹尼斯·罗德曼去朝鲜。天哪。他待在那里，不是吗？是的。他们四处闲逛。我想那是为帕迪鲍尔做的宣传活动。太不可思议了。
not by the castle itself so much. It's a spectacle of Mr Samuel Johnson in this remote place with all its literary associations. And in fact, he wrote a letter to David Garrick, the great actor, that very evening. Indeed, as I have always been accustomed to view him, Dr Johnson, as a permanent London object, it would not be much more wonderful to me to see St. Paul's Church moving along where we now are. And I think you have this sense throughout the trip that Boswell is almost like a kind of documentary director. Right. He's removed someone from his comfortable surroundings and placed him in a la cal where all kinds of adventures might ensue.
所以，是的，但并不比塞缪尔·约翰逊去苏格兰更不可思议。绝对是。所以这是鲍斯威尔对整个旅程感到高兴的关键部分。所以他们看到了考多城堡。他们没有去检查卡洛登战场。我认为这有各种原因。首先，它不在路上。约翰逊不是一个会为了在苏格兰天气里徒步旅行的人。
and he's always kind of framing Johnson in his mind. I have a friend called Rory who once took Dennis Rodman to North Korea. Oh my God. And he stayed there, didn't he? Yeah. They hung around. It was a promotional thing for Paddy Power, I think. So improbable.
好吧。他们没有可以骑的马。而且这是一个非常、非常敏感的地方。我的意思是，你知道，这有点像，我不知道，在伊朗的一个核设施周围乱逛。如果你是一个游客，这可能不是最明智的事情。但很明显，英俊王子查理的历史现在非常占据他们的心头，因为他们到达了因弗内斯，第二天他们特意参观了乔治堡，这是在卡洛登之后建造的堡垒，旨在平定高地。
So, yeah, but no more improbable than Samuel Johnson go to Scotland. Absolutely. And so this is a crucial part of Boswell's delight in the whole trip. So they get to see the castle at Cordor. they do not go to inspect the battlefield of Kuluddin. And I think there are various reasons for this. Firstly, it's off the road. And Johnson isn't a man for taking, I think, a hike across Scottish weather.
所以，是的，但这并不比塞缪尔·约翰逊去苏格兰更不可思议。绝对是这样。所以这是博斯韦尔对整个旅程感到愉悦的关键部分。他们去看了考多城堡，但他们没有去考察卡洛登战场。我认为这有各种原因。首先，它不在大路上。而且我认为约翰逊不是那种会冒着苏格兰的天气去徒步旅行的人。
Okay. They don't have horses that they could ride. And it's a very, very sensitive location. I mean, you know, it's a little bit like, I don't know, poking around a nuclear facility in Iran. It's probably not the most sensible thing to do if you're a tourist. but it's clear that the history of Bonnie Prince Charlie is very much on their minds now because they arrive in Inverness and then the next day they make a point of visiting this Fort George, which is this fortress that had been built in the wake of Culloden to kind of pacify the highlands.
好吧。他们没有可以骑的马。而且那是一个非常非常敏感的地方。我的意思是，你知道，这有点像，我不知道，在伊朗的核设施周围探头探脑。如果你是个游客，这可能不是最明智的做法。但很明显，邦尼王子查理的历史现在非常占据他们的心思，因为他们到达了因弗内斯，第二天他们特意参观了乔治堡，这是一座在卡洛登战役后为了安抚高地而建造的堡垒。
So it's at one end of Loch Ness and Fort Augustus is at the other end of Loch Ness. They're very excited by now because they know that they are going to be following the line of Loch Ness and they're going to be heading out into a country upon which, as Johnson puts, it perhaps no wheel has ever rolled. And so they buy four horses, one for Johnson, one for Boswell, one for Ritter, their giant, bohemian manservant. Oh, yeah. I forgot he was there.
尼斯湖的一端是奥古斯都堡，另一端也是尼斯湖。他们现在非常兴奋，因为他们知道自己将沿着尼斯湖的路线前行，并将前往一片正如约翰逊所说，或许从未有车轮滚过的土地。于是他们买了四匹马，约翰逊一匹，鲍斯威尔一匹，还有他们的巨人波西米亚男仆里特一匹。哦，对了，我忘了他在那儿。
And a fourth to carry their baggage. And that evening, they're last for a while in civilised company. They're in an inn in Inverness, all kinds of, you know, as it usually happens, luminaries have turned up to have a gorp at Dr. Johnson and listened to his conversations. And Johnson is in excellent. form. And they're discussing the state of the world and the name of Joseph Banks comes up. Because the backdrop to this is that Captain Cook has just returned from his trip around the world. Their trip to Australia with the goat. Johnson had actually written the poem in Latin
还有第四匹马用来驮行李。那天晚上，他们暂时最后一次享受文明社会的陪伴。他们住在因弗内斯的一家旅馆里，正如通常发生的那样，各种各样的名流都出现了，想一睹约翰逊博士的风采，听听他的谈话。约翰逊状态极佳。他们正在讨论世界局势，约瑟夫·班克斯的名字被提了出来。因为这一切的背景是库克船长刚刚结束了他的环球航行。他们带着山羊去澳大利亚的旅行。约翰逊实际上用拉丁文写了一首诗
saluting the goat and he's friends with Banks. And he reveals that Banks in Australia had seen a really remarkable animal which Banks terms a kangaroo. and people say, well, what does this kangaroo look like? And Johnson, this incredibly eminent, this incredibly distinguished, this incredibly heavy man, rises to his feet. He stood erect, put out his hands like feelers, and gathering up the tails of his huge brown coat so as to resemble the pouch of the animal made two or three vigorous bounds.
向那只山羊致敬，他和班克斯是朋友。他透露说，班克斯在澳大利亚看到了一种非常奇特的动物，班克斯称之为袋鼠。人们问，这袋鼠长什么样？约翰逊，这位极其显赫、极其尊贵、极其魁梧的男人，站了起来。他挺直身子，伸出双手像触角一样，并提起他那件巨大的棕色外套的下摆，以模仿这种动物的育儿袋，然后用力跳了两三下。
across the room. So the first kangaroo impersonation we've had on the rest of its history. Very exciting. But ahead as even greater excitement because we talked about one exotic and improbable creature in a kangaroo and we might just be about to meet another
跳过房间。所以这是我们历史上第一次袋鼠模仿秀。非常令人兴奋。但前方还有更令人兴奋的事情，因为我们谈到了袋鼠这种奇异且不可思议的生物，而我们可能即将遇见另一种。
because after the break, Johnson and Boswell will be going to Loch Ness. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society and it's Tabby and Dominic here from the book club. Goalhanger's latest show. Now, Tabby, as you know, there are some books that you read once,
因为休息过后，约翰逊和鲍斯威尔就要去尼斯湖了。本集由Folio Society赞助播出，我是书友会的塔比和多米尼克。这是Goalhanger的最新节目。现在，塔比，你知道，有些书你读过一次，
but there are others you especially return to again and again. And those second kind of books, they really deserve to last, don't they? That's what the Folio Society does. They are an independent, employee-owned publisher based in London. Every book is produced with specially commissioned, beautiful artwork and a specially commissioned introduction that puts the story in its context. Folio Society publishes the books we love from Bronte to Dickens, from Margaret Atwood to Tom Holland. The books can feel like works of art in their own right.
但有些书你确实会一遍又一遍地重读。后一种书，它们确实值得流传，不是吗？这就是Folio Society所做的。他们是一家位于伦敦的独立员工持股出版社。每一本书都配有特别委托制作的精美插图，以及特别委托撰写的导读，将故事置于其背景之中。Folio Society出版我们喜爱的书籍，从勃朗特到狄更斯，从玛格丽特·阿特伍德到汤姆·霍兰德。这些书本身就像艺术品一样。
They're built around the text, the stories that last in books that are made to last. If a story matters, keep it properly. Find it at foliosociety.com slash the book club. That's foliosociety.com slash the book club. Marvel Television's Wonder Man An eight-episode series Now streaming on Disney Plus A superhero remake, not exactly what we'd expect
它们围绕着文本构建，让故事在书中永存，让书本身也经久不衰。如果一个故事很重要，就好好保存它。请访问foliosociety.com/thebookclub。网址是foliosociety.com/thebookclub。漫威电视的《神奇人》，八集系列剧，现已在Disney Plus上线。超级英雄翻拍，这可不是我们所期待的
from an Oscar winning director. Action! Simon Williams, audition for Wonder Man. I'm gonna need you to sign this. Assuming you don't have superpowers. I'll never work again if anyone found out. My lips are sealed. Marvel Television's Wonder Man.
来自一位奥斯卡获奖导演的作品。开拍！西蒙·威廉姆斯，为《神奇人》试镜。我需要你签这个。假设你没有超能力。如果有人发现，我就再也无法工作了。我会守口如瓶的。漫威电视的《神奇人》。
All eight episodes now streaming, only on Disney Plus. Welcome back to The Rest is History. It is the 30th of August 1773. Samuel Johnson and James Boswell have left Inverness. They have left the world of stagecoaches and comfortable inns and civilised company and they are riding west into the highlands and their destination, Tom Loch Ness. So Boswell writes about it. Lockness and the road upon the side of it between birch trees with the hills above pleased us much. The scene was a remote and agreeably wild as could be desired.
全八集现已上线，仅在Disney Plus播出。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1773年8月30日。塞缪尔·约翰逊和詹姆斯·鲍斯威尔已经离开了因弗内斯。他们离开了驿站马车、舒适旅馆和文明陪伴的世界，正骑马向西进入高地，目的地是尼斯湖。鲍斯威尔这样写道：尼斯湖以及湖边桦树间的小路，上面的山丘让我们非常愉悦。这里的景色正如所愿，偏远而又令人愉悦地荒凉。
Exciting. So they don't spot the monster. What? Oh, disappointing. Nobody knows the monster exists. That's so disappointing. I guess that's because the monster was invented in 1930s by the Daily Mail, no? Yes, and you can hear our episode about that.
令人兴奋。所以他们没看到水怪。什么？哦，真令人失望。没人知道水怪的存在。太令人失望了。我想那是因为水怪是1930年代《每日邮报》编造出来的，不是吗？是的，你可以听听我们关于那一集的节目。
But even though they don't spot the monster, Boswell does notice a very old woman standing outside a wretched little hovel, as Boswell puts it, made of earth. And it has a window and the way the window is. stopped is with a kind of a circle of turf. This for Boswell is amazing and his kind of documentary maker instincts kick in and he is filled with a desire to see Johnson step inside this hovel. And so they all pile in and inside it they find a pot filled with goat meat bubbling over a peat fire. And Johnson, he's like Louis Thruhe or someone. He's.
但尽管他们没看到水怪，鲍斯威尔确实注意到一位老妇人站在一间破烂的小棚屋外面，正如鲍斯威尔所说，那是用泥土做的。它有一个窗户，窗户是用一种草皮圈堵住的。这对鲍斯威尔来说太神奇了，他那种纪录片制作人的本能被激发了，他渴望看到约翰逊走进这个棚屋。于是他们都挤了进去，在里面他们发现了一个锅，里面装着山羊肉，在泥炭火上冒着泡。约翰逊，他就像路易·特鲁或什么人。他
kind of interviewing this woman, even though she doesn't speak English, she only speaks Gallic or Earth, as Johnson calls it. So to quote Boswell, Mr. Johnson asked her where she slept. I asked one of the guides who asked her in Earth, i.a, gallic. She spoke with a kind of high tone. He told us she was afraid we wanted to go to bed to her. This coquetry or whatever it may be called of so wretched or like being was truly ludicrous. That's very ungallant, by Boswell. He's being very mean about this woman just because she's old and maybe not as pre-possessing as the people with him he can sort on Westminster Bridge. But maybe his reputation had gone before him. Yeah. She thinks, Jesus, Boswell's turned up. I can see he's clutching a pint
在采访这个女人，尽管她不会说英语，她只会说盖尔语，或者约翰逊所说的“泥土语”。引用鲍斯威尔的话，约翰逊先生问她睡在哪里。我问了其中一个向导，他用“泥土语”，也就是盖尔语问她。她说话带着一种高调。他告诉我们，她以为我们想跟她睡觉。这种无论称之为什么的、来自如此可怜生物的调情，真是荒谬可笑。鲍斯威尔这话很不绅士。他因为这个女人老，可能不像他在威斯敏斯特桥上能见到的人那样迷人，就对她很刻薄。但也许他的名声传得比他本人还快。是的。她想，天哪，鲍斯威尔来了。我能看出他手里攥着一品脱
of wine. I'm in for it now. So there is a lot of banter along this theme. Johnson. Johnson makes exactly this point. Yeah. I think he's amused, but he's also embarrassed and he definitely doesn't want to hurt her delicacy. And so he refuses to go into the bedchamber. Boswell inevitably does. And he lights a piece of paper, goes in and inspects it. And he finds it's all, you know, thrillingly basic. It's everything that he'd been hoping for. They then sit down with the old woman and the old woman is incredibly hospitable.
葡萄酒。我这下惨了。所以关于这个主题有很多戏谑。约翰逊。约翰逊正是指出了这一点。是的，我想他觉得很有趣，但也感到尴尬，他绝对不想伤害她的自尊。所以他拒绝进入卧室。鲍斯威尔不可避免地进去了。他点燃一张纸，走进去检查。他发现这一切，你知道，令人兴奋地简陋。这正是他所希望的一切。然后他们和老妇人坐在一起，老妇人非常热情好客。
She gives them both a dram. And then she asks in return, do you have some snuff? And they don't have any snuff. But they reach into their pockets and they both give her a sixpence. And they're chatting away through the interpreter. And she tells Johnson and Boswell that she is as happy as, any woman in Scotland, and then when they go on their way, she sends them with prayers, which she offers up in Gallic.
她给了他们每人一杯酒。然后她反过来问，你们有鼻烟吗？他们没有鼻烟。但他们伸手进兜，每人给了她六便士。他们通过翻译聊得很开心。她告诉约翰逊和鲍斯威尔，她和苏格兰的任何女人一样快乐，当他们继续赶路时，她用盖尔语为他们祈祷。
And Boswell writes, Mr. Johnson was pleased at seeing for the first time such a state of human life. Oh, that's nice. This is what he's been looking for, basically, in the highlands. So they continue on their way following the line of Loch Ness, southwest. And by nightfall, they have reached Fort Augustus, which is at the opposite. sit-end from Inverness, where they stay as guests of the governor. And I have to say that when you read both Johnson and Boswell's account, particularly
鲍斯威尔写道，约翰逊先生很高兴第一次看到这样一种人类生活状态。哦，那真好。这基本上就是他在高地一直在寻找的东西。于是他们继续赶路，沿着尼斯湖向西南方向前进。天黑时，他们到达了奥古斯都堡，它位于因弗内斯的另一端，他们作为总督的客人留宿在那里。我必须说，当你读约翰逊和鲍斯威尔的记述时，特别是
of this stretch along Loch Ness, there's quite a kind of great plains in the 1870s vibe. You know, remote, remote landscapes, forts, the sense of, you know, slight nervousness looking over your shoulder and everything. It reminds me of the stuff we did on stage about some Scottish visitors going. to the new world, going to the United States, in the sort of middle of the 19th century with dogs called peevish. Yes, get eaten by Native Americans. Exactly. Anyway, so they go up into the mountains, don't they? The next day. Yeah. And Johnson is really struck by the wildness. It's exactly what he expected. Everything basically is ticking. It's ticking all
关于尼斯湖这一段，有一种1870年代大平原的感觉。你知道，偏远的风景，堡垒，那种回头看时略带紧张的感觉，等等。这让我想起我们在舞台上做的关于一些苏格兰游客去新世界，去美国，在19世纪中叶，带着叫“暴躁”的狗。是的，被美洲原住民吃掉。没错。总之，他们第二天上山了，不是吗？是的。约翰逊对那种荒凉感触很深。这正是他所期待的。基本上一切都符合
his boxes, right? It's exactly as he hoped and dreamed it would be. And it's about this point that he starts thinking this would make a great book? He does, and he's still pondering this notion that he'd first had in St. Andrews, which is the contrast between all the industry and the bustle of the lowlands and the kind of the emptiness of Northern Scotland. And that evening, they've been travelling over wild, thinly inhabited upland regions. And they climb down and they arrive in Glen Morriston, which is a glen where Bonnie Prince Charles.
他的预期，对吧？这正是他所希望和梦想的样子。就在这时，他开始想，这会是一本好书吗？他确实在想，而且他还在思考他在圣安德鲁斯最初产生的那个想法，即低地的工业和喧嚣与苏格兰北部那种空旷之间的对比。那天晚上，他们一直在荒凉、人烟稀少的山区旅行。他们下山到达了格伦莫里斯顿，这是一个邦尼王子查理曾经在洞穴中避难的山谷。他们环顾四周，发现山谷几乎是空的。这里几乎没有人烟。只有一个地方可以住。他们的房东向他们证实，是的，有70个人已经从山谷去了美国。约翰逊对此感触很深。他在想，你知道，这里有一种深刻的历史变革感，到底发生了什么，是什么解释了这一切？所以他坐在那里思考着。与此同时，鲍斯威尔的情绪是一种典型的鲍斯威尔式的混合体，既有对他们所住的这个糟糕地方的挑剔和厌恶。鲍斯威尔称之为猪圈。但其中又夹杂着一种浪漫的自豪感，感叹风景是多么壮丽，习俗是多么辉煌。
had taken refuge in a cave. And they look around them and they find that the glen is almost empty. It's kind of deserted of habitation. There is one place where they can stay. And their landlord confirms to them, yes, that 70 men had gone out of the glen to America. And Johnson is really struck by this. And he's thinking, you know, there is the sense here of some profound historic change and what is going on, what explains it? So he's kind of sitting there thinking it. Meanwhile, Well, Boswell's emotions are a kind of typically Boswellian mix of kind of fastidious distaste for this awful place they're staying in. But Boswell calls it a sty. But it's intermingled with a sense of romantic pride at how magnificent the scenery is and how splendid all the customs are.
所以先说挑剔的厌恶，他们被带进房间。我的意思是，太糟糕了。显然到处都是臭虫。约翰逊不在乎。约翰逊只是把自己扔在床上，立刻就睡着了。鲍斯威尔躺在他那张可怕的床上，为臭虫感到压力，他有一种奇怪的幻想，觉得一只蜘蛛正从护壁板向我的嘴爬来。他终于睡着了，醒得很早，仍然压力很大，
So the fastidious distaste first, they're shown into their room. I mean, it's awful. It's obviously heaving with bedbugs. Johnson doesn't care. Johnson just kind of throws himself down and immediately falls asleep. Boswell lies on his kind of horrible laddress, stressing out about bedbugs, and he has this weird fancy that a spider was travelling from the windscot towards my mouth. He finally falls asleep, wakes up early, he's still very stressed,
他开始想象房东自己也要移民，可能会为了钱谋杀我们。约翰逊完全不受影响。他躺在那里，头上系着一条彩色手帕，鲍斯威尔不得不推他才让他起来。然后他们去吃早餐。早餐时，鲍斯威尔的心情因为遇到一位邦尼王子查理军队的老兵而立刻转变，这是一位高地人，他在王子刚登陆时就加入了，跟着他深入英格兰，回到卡洛登，并从卡洛登逃脱。
and he began to imagine that the landlord, being about to emigrate himself, might murder us to get our money. Johnson completely unperturbed. He's lying there with a coloured handkerchief tied around his head and Boswell actually has to kind of prod him to get him up. They then go and have breakfast. And at breakfast, Boswell's mood is immediately transformed by meeting a veteran of Bonnie Prince Charlie's army, a Highlander who had signed up with the prince when he'd first landed, gone down with him deep into England, come back to Caluddin and escaped from Caluddin.
于是他讲述了整个故事，鲍斯威尔在听的时候，多次热泪盈眶，并陷入了一种巨大的苏格兰爱国主义狂热中。所以他写道，高地的名字或风笛的声音会激起我的热血，让我充满忧郁与对勇气的敬意，对不幸者的怜悯，对古物的迷信般的敬畏，一种不假思索的战争倾向，简而言之，是一阵感官的冲击。哦，那真好。我的意思是，一阵感官的冲击可能是鲍斯威尔的座右铭。这基本上就是他的全部。所以他处于一种非常浪漫的情绪中。
And so he relates this whole story. and Boswell, as he listens to it, repeatedly finds himself in tears and goes off on a kind of massive Scottish patriotism jag. So he writes, the very highland names or the sound of a bagpipe will stir my blood and fill me with a mixture of melancholy and respect for courage and pity for an unfortunate and superstitious regard for antiquity, an inclination for war without thought, and in shape. short with a crowd of sensations. Oh, that's nice. I mean, a crowd of sensations could be Boswell's motto. That's basically what he's all about. So he's in a very romantic mood.
几天后，也就是9月2日，他们到达了海岸，登上一艘船，被划向斯凯岛。在划船时，他们经过了邦尼王子查理第一次踏上苏格兰土地的地方。鲍斯威尔坐在那里，之前他说过他的热血被激起了。
And a couple of days later, so by now it's the 2nd of September, they've reached the coast and they've boarded a boat and they're being rowed across to sky. And as they're being rode, they passed the very point where Bonnie Prince Charlie had first landed on Scottish soil. And Boswell sits there and previously he said that his blood was stirred.
现在他的思绪被激起了。但基本上，他被这一切深深地触动了。但是。但是，是的。他和约翰逊大吵了一架。怎么回事？他吵了。他有一个巨大的，我的意思是，他们一直相处得很好。
Now his mind is stirred. But basically he's very, very stirred by all of this. But. But, yeah. He's had a massive row with Johnson. What's going on? He has. He had a huge, I mean, they've been getting on so well.
但在他们乘船去斯凯岛的前一天，他们大吵了一架。他们当时正从山上下来。约翰逊骑着这匹小马，他太重了，可怜的小马绊倒了。所以向导伸手去抓缰绳，试图安抚约翰逊和小马。小马很紧张。约翰逊因为小马在他身下倒下而愤怒。约翰逊一直在嘟囔。就在他这样做的时候，向导试图分散约翰逊的注意力并让他高兴起来，他说，
But the day before they get taken in the boat to sky, they've had a massive bust up. So they've been coming down a mountain. Johnson is on this pony and he's so heavy that the poor pony stumbles. So the guide reaches for the bridle and he tries to calm down both Johnson and the pony. The pony is nervous. Johnson is kind of irate that the pony has collapsed under him. And Johnson is kind of rumbling away. And as he's doing this, the guide is trying to distract Johnson and cheer him up and he says,
看那些漂亮的山羊。然后他吹口哨，让它们跳起来。鲍斯威尔觉得这太搞笑了。一个普通的、无知的租马人，竟然以为他能像哄孩子一样哄塞缪尔·约翰逊先生。他笑得停不下来，约翰逊为此大发雷霆。
See such pretty goats. Then he whistles and he makes them jump. And Boswell thinks this is hilarious. A common ignorant horse hireer imagining that he could divert as one does a child, Mr Samuel Johnson. And he can't stop laughing and Johnson has a massive, massive strop about it.
是的，因为约翰逊的尊严被这完全破坏了，对吧？他骑不了小马。小马倒下了，他们正下山。那个家伙把他当孩子一样对待，而鲍斯威尔在嘲笑他。这对约翰逊来说太过分了。这对约翰逊来说绝对太过分了。
Yeah, because Johnson's dignity has been completely undermined by this, right? He can't ride the pony. The pony's collapsing and they're going down the hill. The bloke is treating him like he's a child and Boswell's laughing at him. It's too much for Johnson. It's absolutely too much for Johnson.
这次旅行的主题之一，鲍斯威尔（你知道，他知道这一点，但这是他反复遇到的事情）是约翰逊无法忍受被嘲笑。如果他被嘲笑了，他几乎总是会发脾气。所以他现在发脾气了。鲍斯威尔在这次争吵后，骑马走在前面，试图去探查他们接下来的旅行安排。约翰逊再次将此视为一种个人侮辱。他认为鲍斯威尔觉得他无法像他一样骑得那么快。当鲍斯威尔回来时，他说，你知道吗？我宁愿去偷东西，也不愿做你做的事。
And one of the themes of this whole trip, which Boswell, you know, he'd known this, but it's repeatedly something that he's stumbling up against is that Johnson cannot bear to be made to look ridiculous. And if he does, he almost always loses his temper. And so he loses his temper now. And Boswell, after this kind of bust up, he rides ahead to kind of try and scope out their onward travel arrangements. And Johnson takes this again as a personal insult. He sees it as Boswell thinks that he can't cope with riding as fast as he can. And when Boswell comes back, he says, do you know, I? I should have soon as thought of doing as you have done as picking a pocket.
直到第二天早上他们才和好。又是那句精彩的话。让我们别再提了。哦，我很高兴他们和好了。他们确实和好了。那么他们有什么值得期待的呢？他们还没见过任何氏族首领。不，那才是他们真正想要的。是的。
And it's only the following morning that they make up. And again, there's this brilliant phrase. Let's think no moron't. Oh, I'm glad they're made up anyway. They do make up. So what they've got to look forward to, they haven't met any clan chiefs yet. No, that's what they really want. Yes.
所以有一位氏族首领要来，这就是斯利特麦克唐纳氏族的首领。也就是亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士。跟我说说他。是的，他娶了伊丽莎白·鲍斯威尔，她是鲍斯威尔的远房表亲。所以鲍斯威尔认识亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士，并且实际上在伦敦见过他。在那里，亚历山大爵士发出了正式邀请，因为鲍斯威尔说，哦，我们要去赫布里底群岛。所以他们对此非常兴奋，因为显然他们想见一位真正的赫布里底氏族首领。
So there's a clan chief coming, and this is the chief of Clan MacDonald of Sleet. So Sir Alexander MacDonald. So tell me about him. Yeah, so he's married to Elizabeth Bosville, who's a distant cousin of Boswell. So Boswell knows Sir Alexander MacDonald and had actually met with him in London. And there Sir Alexander had issued a formal invitation because Boswell had said, oh, we're coming to the Hebrides. So they're very excited about this because obviously they want to meet a real Hebridean clan chief.
他们正在接近斯凯岛的南端。他们向外看，看到亚历山大爵士已经来到海边迎接他们。更棒的是，他穿着全套格子呢。这非常令人兴奋，因为格子呢实际上严格来说是非法的。在卡洛登之后，除了在英军服役的高地人外，所有人都被禁止穿格子呢。对。所以亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士穿着传统高地服装出现，这预示着巨大的、巨大的娱乐。更棒的是，麦克唐纳夫人，她非常漂亮，她站在岸边，她正在，引用鲍斯威尔的话，
And they're approaching the southern tip of sky. And they're looking out and they see that Sir Alexander has come down to the sea's edge to welcome them. And what's even better, he is in full tartan. And this is massively exciting because Tartan is actually, strictly speaking, illegal. In the wake of Kludden, it had been prescribed for everyone except for Highlanders serving with the British Army. Right. And so the fact that Sir Alexander McDonald has turned up in the traditional Highland dress, this portends tremendous, tremendous entertainment. What's even better is that Lady MacDonald, who's very beautiful, she is standing at the top of the bank and she is making, quote, Bosn's,
嗯，一种因喜悦而跳跃。所以一切似乎都准备好迎接传统的赫布里底式好客了。除了。这并不是他们得到的。哦，不。亚历山大原来是一个非常糟糕的主人。他很刻薄，真的很无聊，而且粗鲁。没有氏族成员，没有阔刃剑，没有任何“外乡人”的感觉。
well, a kind of jumping for joy. So everything seems set for a taste of traditional Hebridean hospitality. Except that. This is not what they get. Oh, no. So Alexander turns out to be an absolutely terrible host. He's kind of mean, he's really boring, and he's boorish. And there are no Klansmen, there are no claymores, kind of no outlander vibes in any way.
嗯，一种欣喜若狂的感觉。所以一切似乎都准备好去体验传统的赫布里底群岛式好客了。除了这一点。这并不是他们所得到的。哦，不。所以亚历山大原来是一个非常糟糕的主人。他有点刻薄，真的很无聊，而且粗鲁无礼。而且没有氏族成员，没有阔刃大剑，没有任何类似《外乡人》的那种氛围。
The dinner is a shocker. It's kind of undercooked. It's boring. So Alexander hasn't brought his chef with him to the island. The punch, there's almost no alcohol in the punch at all. Oh, that's the lowest thing. That's poor. And Lady MacDonald, whom Boswell remembered as being absolutely enchanting.
晚餐简直糟透了。没煮熟，而且很无聊。亚历山大没带他的厨师去岛上。潘趣酒里几乎没放什么酒精。噢，这真是最糟糕的事了。太寒酸了。还有麦克唐纳夫人，鲍斯威尔记得她曾经非常迷人。
Yeah. It seems, I mean, Johnson says she seems cut out of the cabbage. This woman would sink a 90-gun. ship she is so dull and heavy. Oh, Jesus, that's even more disappointed than the punch. God, this is ticking none of my boxes. So that's very dispiriting. And Boswell is mortified, kind of on his own behalf, but also on behalf of Scotland.
是啊。约翰逊说她看起来像是从卷心菜里刻出来的。这个女人迟钝又沉闷，简直能让一艘90门炮的战舰沉没。天哪，这比潘趣酒更让人失望。上帝啊，这完全不符合我的期待。这太令人沮丧了。鲍斯威尔感到非常羞愧，既是为自己，也是为苏格兰。
This is exactly, he doesn't want Johnson seeing. It's not what he wants at all. Sir Alexander McDonald has let Scotland down. So he has a blazing row with Sir Alexander. Get a better wife, for God's sake. Boswell wants to leave that night. Johnson says, no, we can't. That would be rude.
这正是他不想让约翰逊看到的。这根本不是他想要的。亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士让苏格兰丢脸了。于是他和亚历山大爵士大吵了一架。看在上帝的份上，换个好点的妻子吧。鲍斯威尔当晚就想离开。约翰逊说，不行，我们不能走。那样太没礼貌了。
So they stay there for four days. They head off to go and stay with these other people who've invited them. And from there they're going to make a crossing to the nearby island of Rasi. And they kind of arrive, they're ready to get in the boat, but then the kind of massive storm blows up and they can't make the crossing. So this is very disappointing as well. And Johnson, sensing that Boswell is bored, starts to entertain him with an impersonation of Lady MacDonald, leaning forward with a hand on each cheek and her mouth open. And Boswell, unlike Lord Affleck, his father, is a big fan of impersonations, and he thinks that Johnson has absolutely nailed this impersonation.
于是他们在那儿待了四天。他们动身去拜访其他邀请了他们的人。从那里，他们打算横渡海峡去附近的拉赛岛。他们到达了那里，准备上船，但突然刮起了大风暴，他们无法横渡。这同样令人非常失望。约翰逊察觉到鲍斯威尔很无聊，开始模仿麦克唐纳夫人来逗他开心，他身体前倾，双手托腮，嘴巴张开。鲍斯威尔不像他的父亲奥克莱克勋爵，他非常喜欢模仿，他认为约翰逊模仿得简直绝了。
And he writes, to see such a beauty represented by Mr. Johnson was excessively high. But there are only so many impersonations of Lady MacDonald that can be done over the course of two days. And so by the time the storm finally subsides, they are so ready to cross to Rase. But there are only so many times that Johnson can do an impersonation of Lady MacDonald. And so they're stuck there for two days. And Boswell is just, you know, so depressed. Have all Johnson's criticisms of Scotland, you know, have they been based in fact? I mean, is he right?
他写道，能看到约翰逊先生模仿这样一位美人，真是太高级了。但在两天的时间里，模仿麦克唐纳夫人的次数毕竟有限。所以当风暴终于平息时，他们已经迫不及待地想去拉赛岛了。但约翰逊模仿麦克唐纳夫人的次数也有限。于是他们被困在那里两天。鲍斯威尔简直沮丧透了。约翰逊对苏格兰的所有批评，难道都是基于事实吗？我是说，他是对的吗？
Is Scotland actually a terrible place? So actually Johnson's perspective is slightly different, though, isn't it? Because he's basically struck by how much has changed in Scotland in recent years. He's almost quite mournful and quite melancholy about it. He says basically, clearly there was some romantic, you know, mist shrouded, beautiful Scotland, but it has been destroyed or it's being lost. And that's what really is on his mind. Yeah, so he was writing his book, we came there too late to see what we expected, a people of peculiar appearance and a system of antiquated life. So, Balswell is blaming Sir Alexander for their poor reception.
苏格兰真的是个糟糕的地方吗？其实约翰逊的视角略有不同，不是吗？因为他基本上被苏格兰近年来发生的变化所震撼。他对此感到相当哀伤和忧郁。他基本上说，显然曾经存在过某种浪漫的、云雾缭绕的、美丽的苏格兰，但它已经被摧毁或正在消失。这才是他真正关心的。是的，他在写书时说，我们来得太晚了，没能看到我们所期待的，那种有着独特外貌的人民和古老的生活方式。所以，鲍斯威尔在责怪亚历山大爵士让他们受到了冷遇。
And I think that's reasonable enough. But I think Johnson is seeing it in a slightly deeper kind of profound. historical context. And I think he feels essentially that they've come there too late and that recent history, you know, its effects have been remorseless. There hasn't really been any resisting it because Scotland has joined with England in the Union and as a result has become richer. You know, it's joined this enormous single market.
我认为这很有道理。但我认为约翰逊是在一个更深层、更深刻的历史背景下看待这个问题。我觉得他本质上感到他们来得太晚了，近期的历史及其影响是无情的。这真的无法抗拒，因为苏格兰已经与英格兰合并，结果变得更富裕了。你知道，它加入了这个巨大的单一市场。
It's become more prosperous. It's become a commercial nation, a polite and commercial nation. but only in the lowlands. And Johnson feels that the wealthier the lowlands have grown, the less prepared the elites of Edinburgh and Glasgow have been to put up with the autonomy of the clans. And the law had begun to disarm the clans. Yeah.
它变得更加繁荣。它变成了一个商业国家，一个文明的商业国家。但仅限于低地地区。约翰逊觉得低地地区越富有，爱丁堡和格拉斯哥的精英们就越不愿容忍氏族的自治。法律也开始解除氏族的武装。是的。
So Johnson writes, The chief has lost his formidable retinue and the Highlander walks his heath, unarmed and defenceless, with the peaceable submission of a French peasant or English cottager. And this is something obviously that has struck Johnson only on their to because remember he had brought his pistols with him.
所以约翰逊写道，酋长失去了他强大的随从，高地人走在荒原上，手无寸铁，毫无防备，像法国农民或英国村夫一样温顺地屈服。这显然是约翰逊在旅途中才意识到的，因为别忘了，他随身带着手枪。
But now he finds there aren't any pistols, there aren't any claymores. You know, the Highlanders have have no weapons whatsoever. And this is partly because Scottish laws have disarmed them, but it's also British state repression following the Battle of Kalluddin when, you know, the Hanoverian regime had received this terrible shock. And it's in the wake of that that the tartan had been banned and carrying weapons and all kinds of things. And Johnson writes,
但现在他发现没有手枪，也没有阔刃大剑。高地人没有任何武器。这部分是因为苏格兰法律解除了他们的武装，但这也是卡洛登战役后英国政府的镇压，当时汉诺威王朝受到了可怕的冲击。在那之后，格子呢被禁止，携带武器等各种行为也被禁止。约翰逊写道，
their pride had been crushed by the heavy hand of a vindictive conqueror, and that chiefs had degenerated from patriarchal rulers to rapacious landlords, and that many of the chiefs, rather than stay in their ancestral strongholds, surrounded by their clansmen, that most of them have migrated southwards to the lowlands, to Glasgow, to Edinburgh. Some of them have even gone to London, and it doesn't surprise Johnson at all to learn that Sir Alexander MacDonald, had been educated at Eton.
他们的骄傲被复仇心重的征服者用铁腕粉碎了，酋长们从家长式的统治者堕落成了贪婪的房东，许多酋长不再待在祖传的堡垒里，被族人簇拥，而是大多向南迁移到了低地，到了格拉斯哥，到了爱丁堡。有些人甚至去了伦敦，得知亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士是在伊顿公学受的教育，约翰逊一点也不感到惊讶。
So... Yeah, they're losing their Scottishness. Yeah, I mean, certainly they're losing their status as a, you know, a Hebridean clan chief. The clan chiefs are all going to Eton. And the Klansmen, rather than kind of choose to mouldering glens or on the aisles or whatever, are increasingly leaving for America, either to fight for the British army there or to set up as colonists. And Johnson feels that it's not really the union. that's brought this about, that it's not even Kuluddin that has doomed them, that it is actually
所以……是的，他们正在失去苏格兰特色。是的，我的意思是，他们肯定正在失去作为赫布里底群岛氏族酋长的地位。氏族酋长们都去了伊顿公学。而族人们，与其选择在阴暗的峡谷或岛屿上生活，不如越来越多地前往美国，要么为英军作战，要么去当殖民者。约翰逊觉得这并不是联合带来的结果，甚至不是卡洛登注定了他们的命运，而实际上是
just the kind of the inexorable way of things, that this is how a commercializing nation, a prospering nation, that there are victims. Doesn't it go back to your parallel that you made earlier on with the Plains Indians and visitors to the Great Plains, that you could conceivably visit the Great Plains in the late 19th century and you take your pistols thinking this part of you that thinks gosh a week to be taken prisoner by the by the sue or something and you get there and it's all gone and it's all changed and and it's partly repression and it's partly the process of you know capitalism and industrialization and urbanization and all those kinds of things and this is a preview of that
一种不可阻挡的趋势，这就是一个商业化、繁荣的国家的发展方式，总会有牺牲品。这难道不回到了你之前做的那个关于平原印第安人和大平原游客的类比吗？你本可以想象在19世纪末访问大平原，你带着手枪，心想“天哪，要是被苏族人俘虏该多刺激”，结果你到了那里，一切都消失了，一切都变了，这部分是因为镇压，部分是因为资本主义、工业化、城市化等进程，而这正是那一切的预演。
no yeah and i think what johnson says about the process of immiseration that are essentially destroying the traditions of the highlands could equally be applied to the plains indians so he writes, misery is caused for the most part, not by a heavy crush of disaster, but by the corrosion of less visible evils, which canker enjoyment and undermine security. The visit of an invader is necessarily rare, but domestic animosities allow no cessation. And so this is the judgment that he delivers in his book on the Western Islands. You know, and it's a kind of somber one. It's profound one. I mean, I think that's true more generally. I mean, you could apply it perhaps to life in Western democracies at the moment if you wanted to.
不，是的，我认为约翰逊关于导致高地传统毁灭的贫困化过程的论述，同样适用于平原印第安人。所以他写道，苦难的产生，大多不是因为灾难的重压，而是因为那些不那么明显的邪恶的侵蚀，它们腐蚀了快乐，破坏了安全。入侵者的造访必然是罕见的，但内部的敌意却永无止境。这就是他在《西方群岛游记》中给出的评价。这是一种阴郁的评价。也是深刻的。我的意思是，我认为这在更广泛的意义上是正确的。你可以把它应用到当下的西方民主国家生活中，如果你愿意的话。
Yeah. And there are people in Scotland when this book comes out who say, well, this is just because Johnson hates Scotland. I don't think this is true. I don't think actually, I think Johnson has a wonderful time in Scotland. He's writing as a man who has an instinctive sympathy for the underdog, but he is also writing as someone who in the course of his travels does actually see enough of the traditional Highland ways to feel very, very wistful for their decline.
是的。当这本书出版时，苏格兰有些人说，这只是因为约翰逊讨厌苏格兰。我不认为这是真的。我不认为，实际上，我认为约翰逊在苏格兰度过了一段美好的时光。他作为一个对弱者有本能同情心的人在写作，但他也是一个在旅途中确实看到了足够多的高地传统方式，从而对它们的衰落感到非常、非常惆怅的人。
And what he sees, he enjoys so much that he, from this point on, will always refer to his travels in the Western Isles as the pleasantest part of my life. Oh, that's nice. So, Boswell, actually, needn't have worried. Johnson isn't having a bad time. He hadn't been put off by Sir Alexander McDonald's sticking his fork into a liver pudding while his guests were kept standing. He hasn't been put off by the storms.
他所看到的让他非常享受，以至于从那时起，他总是把他在西方群岛的旅行称为“我一生中最愉快的时光”。噢，那真不错。所以，鲍斯威尔其实不必担心。约翰逊并没有过得不开心。他没有因为亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士在客人站着的时候把叉子插进肝脏布丁里而感到扫兴。他也没有被风暴吓倒。
I mean, you know, it's Western Scotland. He's Johnson's expecting storms. And the two months in the Hebrides that follow this kind of slightly unfortunate introduction to Sky, they are a triumph. So Recy, when they finally reach it, proves an absolute ball. There's everything that they'd been hoping for from Sir Alexander MacDonald. There's fiddling, there's dancing.
我的意思是，那是苏格兰西部。约翰逊预料到了会有风暴。在这次对斯凯岛略显不幸的介绍之后，随后的两个月赫布里底群岛之行简直是一场胜利。所以，当他们最终到达拉赛岛时，那绝对是一场狂欢。那里有他们从亚历山大·麦克唐纳爵士那里期待的一切。有小提琴，有舞蹈。
And even though Johnson sits out the reels, he's absolutely in his element. and Boswell wrote in great relief. Mr Johnson was in fine spirits. He said, this is truly the patriarchal life. This is what we came to find. They come back to Sky and they travel to Kingsborough and there they meet the ultimate in living Jacobite history.
即使约翰逊没有参加里尔舞，他也完全沉浸其中。鲍斯威尔如释重负地写道：约翰逊先生精神焕发。他说，这才是真正的家长式生活。这就是我们来寻找的东西。他们回到斯凯岛，前往金斯伯勒，在那里他们见到了活着的詹姆斯党历史的终极代表。
And this is Flora MacDonald, the woman who had saved Bonnie Prince Charlie. And she had escorted the wanderer, as Boswell calls him, disguised as her Irish maid, Betty Burke. And it has to be said that, according to Flora MacDonald, he didn't make a very convincing Irish maid. She'd brought him from the Outer Hebrides to Sky. And from Sky, Bonnie Prince Charlie had been taken onwards to the mainland again
这就是弗洛拉·麦克唐纳，那个救了“英俊王子查理”的女人。她护送着鲍斯威尔所说的“流浪者”，伪装成她的爱尔兰女仆贝蒂·伯克。必须说，据弗洛拉·麦克唐纳所言，他并没有装扮成一个令人信服的爱尔兰女仆。她把他从外赫布里底群岛带到了斯凯岛。从斯凯岛，英俊王子查理又被带到了大陆，
and put on a ship and taken back to France. And, again, Boswell, the documentary director, To see Mr Samuel Johnson salute Miss Flora MacDonald was a wonderful romantic scene to me. And what's even more romantic is that they stay in Florida McDonnell's house and Johnson sleeps in the very bed that Bonnie Prince Charlie had slept in. So if you're a Bonnie Prince Charlie tourist, I mean, you know, this is incredible. I mean, if you're an old Tory like Samuel Johnson with Jacobite's sympathies, this must be absolutely fantastic. Absolute heaven.
然后被送上一艘船回到了法国。同样，鲍斯威尔，这位纪录片导演写道：看到塞缪尔·约翰逊先生向弗洛拉·麦克唐纳小姐致敬，对我来说是一个美妙而浪漫的场景。更浪漫的是，他们住在弗洛拉·麦克唐纳的房子里，约翰逊睡在英俊王子查理睡过的那张床上。所以如果你是一个英俊王子查理的游客，这简直不可思议。如果你是一个像塞缪尔·约翰逊那样的老托利党人，并且同情詹姆斯党，这一定棒极了。绝对的天堂。
Yeah. So he really is having a brilliant time. And I think the final highlight for Johnson is perhaps the most moving of all. And this, they go to Mull and then they take a crossing, a very short crossing, to Iona, which is a holy island for the Scots. And indeed, I think for any British Christian, St. Columba, the Irish monk, had founded a monastery there back in 563. commemorated as the great cradle of Scottish Christianity and Johnson feels an immense surge of emotion visiting it
是的。所以他确实度过了一段辉煌的时光。我认为约翰逊最后的亮点也许是最感人的。他们去了马尔岛，然后进行了一次非常短的横渡，到达了爱奥那岛，这对苏格兰人来说是一座圣岛。事实上，我认为对于任何英国基督徒来说也是如此，爱尔兰僧侣圣科伦巴早在563年就在那里建立了一座修道院。它被纪念为苏格兰基督教的摇篮，约翰逊在访问时感到一种巨大的情感涌动。
and he wrote about it in a very famous line that man is little to be envied whose patriotism would not gain force upon the plane of marathon or whose piety would not grow warmer among the ruins of Iona nice so for Boswell you described him a documentary maker. I mean, he's got all the shots he wanted. He's got Johnson in Bonnie Prince Charlie's bed. He's got Johnson looking, you know, melancholy and thoughtful and stirred with a
他在一行非常著名的诗句中写道：如果一个人的爱国主义在马拉松平原上不能增强，或者他的虔诚在爱奥那岛的废墟中不能变得更加热烈，那么这个人是不值得羡慕的。真好。所以对于鲍斯威尔，你形容他是一位纪录片制作人。我的意思是，他得到了他想要的所有镜头。他拍到了约翰逊睡在英俊王子查理的床上。他拍到了约翰逊看起来忧郁、深思，在爱奥那岛的废墟中被宗教情感所触动。他拍出了一部了不起的电影。
religious feeling in the ruins of Iona. I mean, he's made a tremendous film. Yeah. And so all their kind of, you know, memories of rouse about ponies and so on have ended up pretty much forgotten. And in fact, there are only two episodes during the whole tour around the Hebrides, which it would subsequently cause Boswell pain to recall. And the first of these had occurred on the 16th of September. Johnson had a cold but was otherwise in fine form, and he's talking away about a whole host of things. And he suddenly, it seems to Boswell, goes off on a mad one.
是的。所以他们关于小马之类的所有争吵记忆基本上都被遗忘了。事实上，在整个赫布里底群岛的巡回演出中，只有两件事后来让鲍斯威尔回想起来感到痛苦。第一件事发生在9月16日。约翰逊感冒了，但精神状态很好，他谈论着各种各样的事情。突然，在鲍斯威尔看来，他变得疯狂了。
Johnson says, I have often thought that if I kept a Sorrelio, So a harrim The ladies should all wear linen gowns or cotton I mean stuff's made of vegetable substances And he's saying this because They've been talking about How linen is
约翰逊说，我常想，如果我养一个后宫，女士们都应该穿亚麻长袍或棉布长袍，我的意思是，用植物纤维做的东西。他这么说是因为他们一直在谈论亚麻比任何动物制品好得多。
kind of vastly preferable to anything with animal substances But it is a slightly Unexpected Left Field Sally And the fact that he said I have often thought That if I kept a harim
但这确实是一个有点出人意料的离题。他竟然说“我常想，如果我养一个后宫”。
I mean Boswell finds this so unexpected that he bursts out Johnson doesn't like that. Johnson doesn't like this because he feels that he is now an object of ridicule. And in the kind of the published version of his journals, Boswell says he was too proud to submit, even for a moment, to be the object of ridicule and instantly retaliated with keen, sarcastic wit and a variety of degrading images.
鲍斯威尔觉得这太出乎意料了，他脱口而出。约翰逊不喜欢这样。约翰逊不喜欢这样，因为他觉得他现在成了嘲笑的对象。在出版的日记版本中，鲍斯威尔说他太骄傲了，甚至一刻也不愿成为嘲笑的对象，并立即以敏锐、讽刺的机智和各种贬损的意象进行了报复。
And Boswell doesn't specify what these degrading images are in the book, but in his journal he had done. And essentially, what Johnson had done was to say, oh, well, if I had a, I had a, you know, Harim, you would be the eunuch. And there are some quite deep waters here, I feel, because of course, Boswell had wanted to keep a Harim for himself. He talked about that with him so. And the idea of being a eunuch to Johnson,
鲍斯威尔在书中没有具体说明这些贬损的意象是什么，但在他的日记里他写了。本质上，约翰逊所做的是说，哦，好吧，如果我有一个后宫，你就是那个太监。我觉得这里面水很深，因为当然，鲍斯威尔自己也想养一个后宫。他曾和约翰逊谈过这个。而成为约翰逊的太监的想法，
I mean, it just seems so wrong. It hits him on various levels because, A, Boswell is so priapic that for him to be a eunuch, to be unmanned in this way is an insult to his, to his masculinity. But also he kind of is Johnson's eunuch. already? Well, he's the attendant, isn't he? He's the subordinate figure.
这似乎太不对劲了。它在多个层面上打击了他，因为第一，鲍斯威尔如此好色，以至于被阉割，以这种方式被剥夺男性气概，是对他男性尊严的侮辱。但他也已经是约翰逊的“太监”了，不是吗？他是随从，不是吗？他是从属角色。
Yes, he's Johnson's super fan. Yeah. So I think there's a lot going on there. And so Boswell writes, I would gladly expunge from my mind every trace of this severe retort. And you can see why. It's clearly striking him on all kinds of levels.
是的，他是约翰逊的超级粉丝。是的。所以我认为那里发生了很多事情。于是鲍斯威尔写道，我愿从我的脑海中抹去这次严厉反驳的每一丝痕迹。你可以看出原因。这显然在各个层面上打击了他。
Then there is a second episode, which is very famous. And again, Boswell could not bring himself to relate it in full. And it takes place at the very end of their journey. they've come back from the Hebrides, they're heading down to Edinburgh, but before they reach Edinburgh, they head southwards to the one place in Scotland that Johnson had always said he'd wanted to see, in which Boswell had always longed to show him, and that, of course,
然后是第二个插曲，非常出名。同样，鲍斯威尔无法让自己完整地讲述它。它发生在他们旅程的最后。他们从赫布里底群岛回来，正前往爱丁堡，但在到达爱丁堡之前，他们向南前往苏格兰唯一一个约翰逊一直说想看，而鲍斯威尔一直渴望带他去看的地方，那当然就是
is the ancestral seat of the Boswell's Affleck. Oh, that's risky. It is risky. Because his father, his father is that, what is he, he's a wig, he's a Presbyterian, he's a Hanoverian, he's got no sense of fun or humour. I mean, I can't see him getting on with Samuel Johnson. I mean, he has got a sense of humour, but it's very sharp and bitter and kind of piercing. It's not jolly.
鲍斯威尔的祖宅奥克莱克。噢，那很冒险。确实很冒险。因为他的父亲，他的父亲是那种……他是什么人？他是辉格党人，是长老会教徒，是汉诺威派，他一点幽默感都没有。我的意思是，我看不出他能和塞缪尔·约翰逊相处。我的意思是，他有幽默感，但非常尖锐、刻薄且刺人。那不是快乐的幽默。
And Boswell knows this. And so he says, you know, if Lord Affleck had not invited Johnson, I would not have taken him there. Because, you know, he'd be fearing the worst, you know, worried about fireworks. But Lord Affleck had insisted. And so Boswell and Johnson had duly arrived at Affleck on the 2nd of November. And to begin with, everything goes well. Both men behave themselves. Johnson has a lovely time being led up by Boswell to inspect the ruins of the old castle on the, you know, on the gorge above the rivers.
鲍斯威尔知道这一点。所以他说，如果奥克莱克勋爵没有邀请约翰逊，我就不会带他去那里。因为他会担心最坏的情况，担心会发生冲突。但奥克莱克勋爵坚持要邀请。于是鲍斯威尔和约翰逊于11月2日如期抵达奥克莱克。起初，一切都很顺利。两人表现得都很得体。约翰逊在鲍斯威尔的带领下参观了河上峡谷上方古城堡的废墟，度过了一段美好的时光。
And the days pass and things seem to be perfectly amiable between Lord Affleck and Johnson. But then on the 6th of November, disaster. So Lord Affleck has a collection of medals and he keeps them in the library. in his great classical house that he's just had built. And he pulls him out and he shows him to Johnson. When Oliver Cromwell's coin unfortunately introduced Charles I first and Toryism. It's like when we do a thing and we end up with George Ours, the publisher and historian. Couple loft.
日子一天天过去，阿弗莱克勋爵和约翰逊之间的关系似乎非常融洽。但到了11月6日，灾难发生了。阿弗莱克勋爵收藏了一批奖章，并把它们保存在他刚建好的宏伟古典式住宅的图书馆里。他把奖章拿出来给约翰逊看。当奥利弗·克伦威尔的硬币不幸引出了查理一世和托利主义时，就像我们做了一件事，结果却引出了出版商兼历史学家乔治·奥尔斯一样。真是荒唐。
And we accidentally praise Oliver Cromwell and he goes ballistic and starts shouting about Charles I. This is what happens, right? This is the essence of Toryism. the belief that Charles I should not have had his head chopped off. Yeah. Lord Affleck is, is, is,
我们不小心赞美了奥利弗·克伦威尔，他立刻暴跳如雷，开始大喊大叫关于查理一世的事。事情就是这样，对吧？这就是托利主义的本质。即认为查理一世不应该被砍头。是的。阿弗莱克勋爵是，是，是，
is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, is, minds that they have vertebrae in their necks. Yeah. And Johnson just explodes and, and, the row goes on and on. And Boswell, he can't avoid mentioning it in his book because it's really
是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，是，提醒他们脖子里还有脊椎骨。是的。约翰逊直接爆发了，争吵没完没了。而鲍斯韦尔，他在书中无法避免提到这件事，因为它确实
quite famous. The news of it leaks out. But he, he, he refuses to go into details. It would certainly be very unbecoming in me to exhibit my honored father and my respected friend as intellectual gladiators for the entertainment of the public. And you slightly feel reading that, well, I mean, nothing has stopped you doing exactly that before. I mean, Boswell only has to hear a conversation and he's transcribing it, but...
非常出名。消息泄露了出去。但他拒绝透露细节。他说：将我尊敬的父亲和受人尊敬的朋友作为供公众娱乐的智力角斗士展示出来，这对我来说肯定是非常不体面的。读到这里，你多少会觉得，好吧，以前没什么能阻止你做同样的事。我的意思是，鲍斯韦尔只要听到一段对话就会把它记录下来，但是……
But not when they've gone head to head. No. That's the difference. These two men who are so important in his life, it kind of is his ultimate nightmare. But to reiterate, basically everything else that Johnson has said on this tour, Boswell has written down, they are there in his journal. they are ready to be used. Johnson has decided on the course of the tour
但当他们针锋相对时，他却没这么做。不，这就是区别。这两个对他生命中如此重要的人，这简直是他终极的噩梦。但重申一下，基本上约翰逊在这次旅行中所说的每一句话，鲍斯韦尔都写了下来，它们都在他的日记里，随时准备被使用。约翰逊已经决定了这次旅行的路线，
that he's going to write a book. Boswell has already, even before going on the tour with Johnson, decided that his ultimate ambition is to write a biography of Johnson once Johnson is dead. And so this is one of the reasons why he has been kind of occasionally goading Johnson.
他打算写一本书。鲍斯韦尔甚至在与约翰逊同行之前，就已经决定他最终的抱负是在约翰逊去世后为他写一部传记。所以这也是他偶尔会激怒约翰逊的原因之一。
He wants kind of good copy. Throughout the tour, he's pressing Johnson to tell him details about his life. And it's almost the case that Johnson is so busy writing up what Johnson says that he doesn't actually have much time to talk to Johnson. Johnson and Boswell have both returned from this trip with the kind of raw material for future books that both of them had wanted. And Boswell absolutely feels I do now have the material for a kind of a biography of Johnson that will be unlike any biography that has ever been written. However, even as he is plotting this, he is aware that he has a rival. Someone who actually is more familiar and certainly more intimate with Johnson than Boswell has ever been.
他想要好的素材。在整个旅程中，他不断催促约翰逊告诉他关于他生活的细节。情况几乎变成了约翰逊忙于记录约翰逊所说的话，以至于他实际上没有太多时间与约翰逊交谈。约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔都带着他们各自想要的未来书籍的原始素材从这次旅行中归来。鲍斯韦尔绝对感觉到，我现在确实拥有了为约翰逊写一部传记的素材，这将是前所未有的传记。然而，即使在他策划这一切的时候，他也意识到自己有一个竞争对手。一个实际上比鲍斯韦尔更熟悉、当然也更亲近约翰逊的人。
And this is a rival who isn't just a woman, but more than that, Dominic, a woman from Wales. Cricky, well that is a bombshell. Very exciting. If you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can get that episode right now. If you're not, and you would like to join our own depopulated Hebridean clan, then please head to the rest is history.com.
而这个竞争对手不仅是一位女性，多米尼克，更重要的是，她还是一位来自威尔士的女性。天哪，这真是一个重磅炸弹。非常令人兴奋。如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以收听那一集。如果你还不是，并且想加入我们这个人口稀少的赫布里底群岛部落，请前往therestishistory.com。
So next time, on the Restis History, a sentence I thought I would never say, we will be talking about a Welsh woman. Goodbye. Bye. Bye-bye. Getting ready for a game means being ready for any. like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember 988, Canada's Suicide Crisis Helpline.
所以下一次，在“历史余韵”节目中，我从未想过我会说出这样一句话，我们将讨论一位威尔士女性。再见。再见。拜拜。为比赛做准备意味着要为任何情况做好准备。就像带一根备用球杆一样。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我记住了988，加拿大的自杀危机求助热线。
It's good to know, just in case. Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder anytime. 988 suicide crisis helpline is funded by the government in Canada. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
知道这一点很好，以防万一。任何人都可以随时拨打或发送短信，从受过培训的接线员那里获得免费的保密支持。988自杀危机求助热线由加拿大政府资助。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。